was los leute, es waren so viele da, es ist noch früh, guck mal es sind nicht mal 10
es ist was passiert was ich nie für möglich gehalten hätte
nein also nicht dass die nicht dass die battlefield beta verlängert wird oder
irgendwie sowas das ist das nicht zumindest nicht dass ich mitbekommen
habe ich habe gelesen microsoft hat selbst eine anleitung gepostet das
müssen wir gleich mal gucken aber microsoft hat selbst eine anleitung
gepostet wie man die beschränkung von windows 11 umgeht wo ich mich dann
frage wenn microsoft selbst eine anleitung postet um ihre eigenen
aufgestellten beschränkungen zu umgehen warum sind diese beschränkungen überhaupt
doch da das leuchtet mir absolut nicht ein aber
windows logik wahrscheinlich ja habe ich habe ich heute morgen gelesen los ja
microsoft zeigt tritt zur umgehung der anforderung warum warum existiert
domtoretto dafür warum existieren die die anforderungen einschränkungen überhaupt
wenn microsoft selbst zeigt wie man sie umgeht was das verstehe ich nicht aber
gleichzeitig war das support dafür dass in die tat umzusetzen das ist wieder
so ein halbherziges ding mit ihr haben schiss dass zu wenig leute das verwenden
dass die leute zu sehr rumschreien deswegen sagen sie hier so könnt ihr es
machen aber aber ihr solltet das nicht machen logik logik pur wieder bei
microsoft am start
wie kann ich eigentlich überprüfen ob mein system tpm 2 0 hat tpm 2 0 check
wie überprüft man das eigentlich so prüft ihr ob euer system ein tpm
was tpm cpl das muss man bestimmt cmd machen oder tpm cpl so oder run oder was
oder wo run tpm was tpm msc ah yes und wo sehe ich jetzt da was ich habe
oh ja dann ich dann nicht dann dann lasse ich halt wenn es nicht will
was wird es als admin starten muss er bestimmt als admin starten oder
oh powershell hacks am start hier tpm tool get device information
das wird auch alles gut oder wie wie macht man das diese microsoft fehler
meldung sind auch immer genial also was war das tpm msc ok run als admin
ok compatible trusted platform module cannot be found on this computer und
jetzt ich kann es auch sein dass es in bios abgeschaltet im efe abgeschaltet
habe oder wahrscheinlich aber ist jetzt zwar jetzt war ich hab mich damit nie
beschäftigt ist das eine sache in der cpu oder ist das eine sache auf dem
mainboard es ist eine sache auf dem mainboard oder dementsprechend könnte
ich einfach mal gucken deswegen könnte ich einfach mal gucken
bei meinem bei meinem rechner ob bei der bei dem hier selbstbau details zu
handeln ich gucke einfach beim im handbuch von
meinem mainboard ich habe nämlich ein s rock fatality z3 70 professional gaming
i7 da geht aber eigentlich noch ein bisschen mehr ja da könnte man schon
ein bisschen mehr reinpacken in den namen
ich habe ich habe ein 8700 k was ist das das ist ein welcher welcher lake
kopf koffi lake habe ich das in der cpu
tritt nichts von tpm also habe ich tpm 2 wenn der chat mir das sage ich vertraue
dem chat der chat würde der chat würde mir niemals was erzählen was nicht
stimmt also wenn der chat sagt dass das dann dann dann glaube ich euch das
ich muss es wahrscheinlich bios noch einschalten ja ich hier was von tpm oder
so tpm trusted vielleicht hier trusted naja inte das was anderes trusted
execution ab ist das das was zu melddown geführt hat so trostet alles
ok dann wird es dann wird funktionieren dann wird es funktionieren ich habe es
einfach im bios abgeschaltet was aber witzig ist ne ich habe es im bios
abgeschaltet aber software emulation mäßig geht es trotzdem weil ich kann
windows 11 laufen lassen mit tpm inner vm das simuliert einfach in tpm
vor allem wer das funktioniert guckt klappt eigentlich eigentlich der witz
oder power off wir brauchen das jetzt nicht dein board hat einen tpm header
kann es was ranstecken aber ich glaube nicht nee das angeblich der chat sagt es
ist der chat sagt es ist in der cpu drinne also ist das ist das alles gut
dann ist das in der cpu dann ist dann dann ist all dann mache ich mir keine
lang aber ich will gar kein windows 11 hat jemand von euch schon geupgraded
warum sie sich kümmern sollten so so microsoft
echt das hätte ich gerade so viele haben schon geupgraded guck mal hier das
hätte ich nicht gedacht ich hätte gedacht dass die meisten leute
erst mal sagen ich warte mal ab also ich werde auf jeden fall auch abwarten
mal gucken ob wir noch das update was wir noch das update mir vorschlägt oh dann
kann ich ja gar nicht abgreifen
future update ja dann nicht jetzt nicht definitiv nicht jetzt
ich werde ich werde das auch ich werde auch warten bei mir läuft alles bis auf
veloranda das wird durch kacke überprüfen jetzt auch
aha ja velorand anti cheat ist ja mittlerweile auch schon advances root
kit übrigens wenn ihr mal richtig
richtig leute am abbleiben über battlefield sehen wollt geht auf reddit
die komplett die sind komplett am eskalieren
die sind die drehen alle durch also hier ist wirklich hier ist wirklich die sind
wirklich komplett die komplett am rum und alle her
haben sie auch recht werde wahrscheinlich auf windows 11
upgraden wenn mein nächstes hardware upgrade kommt ja mein nächstes
hardware upgrade war kam schon theoretisch vor über einem jahr aber es
ist ja keine hardware verfügbar kriegst du keine grafikkarten keine cpu ist das
heißt ich muss bis zur nächsten generation warten bis das war halt
wirklich sinnvoll und so lang behalte ich mein rechner 8700 k 1080 ti vollkommen
ausreichend
überhaupt kein problem
es soll dann gibt schon motz motz menüs für battlefield geben ja es gibt schon
cheat seiten die cheats anbieten für battlefield 2042 wenn ich jetzt nicht
dem stream zeigen aber ist schon im vollen gange trotz easy anti cheat an
die meisten haben nicht gehabt gehört aber 30 prozent haben sie es mehr als ich
gedacht habe mehr als gedacht habe
abschließendes fazit 2002 eigentlich alles das was ich im letzten video
gesagt habe das spiel machen bock hauptsächlich dadurch dass halt das das
movement stimmt die geschwindigkeit stimmt wenn man halt diesen ein
specialist spielt der sommer was mit dem stream los
das geht das stream noch
oje oje geht noch was ist hier los oder faun oder faun
geht wieder
oder faun
wird camping
kurz leg kann ich nichts machen liegt nicht an mir
bei mir war man jetzt auch wahrscheinlich bis ob er schuld sie bis
ob er wurde auf hauptsächlich
ja also ganz kurzes fazit wie gesagt im prinzip das was im letzten video auch
gesagt hat es macht spaß durch das movement mit dem einzigen specialist
den du spielen kannst und halt falls irgendwie mal was neues battlefield
mäßiges es macht jetzt schon echt spaß kurzfristig aber das spiel hat so
extrem viele probleme und auch so viele undurchdachte sachen dass ich einfach
glaube wenn das wirklich in auch nur ansatzweise diesem zustand rauskommt
und ich rede jetzt nicht von performance oder von klitsch animation rektor
effekten oder sonst irgendwas also ich rede wirklich von den den
grundlegenden design problem in der spiel hat wenn es in dies wenn es so in
diesem in diesem zustand rauskommt dann habe ich das dumme gefühl das wird
ungefähr den gleichen das gleiche schicksal allein wie battlefield 3
battlefield 5
was ich nicht hoffe
ich würde mir wirklich wünschen dass das spiel richtig abgeht
naja wisst ihr was weil es der serious max gerade sagt das ist das habe ich mir
tatsächlich auch gedacht ich habe ich ich so ins geheim dachte ich mir dass
die jetzt diese beta machen die halt sehr unpolished ist was obwohl es
eigentlich eher demo demo zeit wäre und daraufhin sagen wir haben das spieler
feedback gehört wir pushen das release datum back auf mit den nächsten jahres
das denke ich mir so ins geheim vielleicht war das der hintergrund aber
ich glaube es nicht die wollen weihnachtsgeld haben und ea wird sich
das nicht durch die lappen gehen lassen wollen
dazu kann ich sagen ja fand ich auch erst blöd
es gab viele close quarter situationen wo dieses um die ecke gucken von
battlefield 4 wann ist das release geplant in zwei wochen oder so ist nicht
so lang dauert nicht mal lang warte mal ne warte mal
battlefield 2042 release date nicht mal lang
ane in dem monat in dem monat nicht zwei wochen vier wochen fünf wochen in dem
monat
so und
seck
ja ich fand es am anfang auch blöd dass es nicht geht aber es ist eh alles schon
so kleinteilig es ist ganz gut dass es nicht geht du musst jetzt schon pixel
zählen dass du gegner siehst welche design probleme gibt das also wenn du
mich in der runde renten hören willst über das battlefield was für probleme
gibt dann guckt einfach mein letztes video an da ist 15 minuten drüber
ausgelassen
ein monat noch ein monat noch bedeutet in der regel sind eigentlich fertig so
anscheinend geht es wieder das mares dange für den sub
übrigens leute auch wenn ich ich vorgelesen habe
dankeschön für die ganzen selbst die letzten drei tage bei den battlefield
streams gekriegt habe ich habe kaum was mitbekommen weil ich so immer war im
game nur wenn ich teilweise gehört habe dass es bling gemacht hat
ja da wird sich darüber gestritten wie alt es wirklich ist auf jeden fall es
ist auf jeden fall ein paar monate alt aber nicht desto trotz die server seite
ist auf jeden fall neuer alles andere wäre bescheuert warum sollen die jetzt
was rausbringen was uralt ist und die server seite auch uralt das bringt ihn
ja keinen mehr wert hier müssen da schon gegen die aktuelle
server seite testen das heißt die ganzen problematiken und rum geruckel und
sonst was da ist fraglich ob das tatsächlich bei release besser ist weil
die server seite ist ja die gleiche gut vielleicht verarbeitet der klein nicht
alle packets was auch immer was ziemlich merkwürdig wäre weil es
absolut basic ist das netzwerk technisch überhaupt was funktioniert aber nicht
desto trotz das spiel hat so viele grundlegenden probleme also auch
entscheidungen ich mein man muss sich nur mal den aufbau der map angucken dass
das nix anderes ist wie im endeffekt flache wiese mit drei häusern drauf und
punkte am arsch der welt mit mit 30 kilometer rennen dazwischen das ist
einfach was wo man den richtig überlegt hat man wollte einfach mehr spieler man
wollte mehr von allem ohne dass es wirklich passt auch diese sachen wie die
sport wie die wie die wie die sektoren und flaggen gerade aufgebaut sind sorgt
einfach dafür dass du auf den punkt rennst wo keiner ist weil da geht ja
gerade nix dann bist du auf den punkt beginnst den punkt einzunehmen die
gegner haben noch eine halbe minute zeit rein zu spornen und es spornen 30
gegner 30 gegner waren muss man mal erwähnen vorher ungefähr das gesamte
gegner team und jetzt ist es halbe gegner team und da machst du halt nix mit
deinen drei leuten wo du den den 5 leuten oder vier leuten wo du den punkt
gerade stürmst weil die spornen einfach links rechts oben unter dir vor dir in
deinem bobs die spornen die spornen überall und du kannst es einfach du
kannst es ein du kannst es nicht halten nicht wirklich also die bete hat
glaube ich kaum jemand überzeugt es zu kaufen und deswegen denke ich mir
insgeheim vielleicht war das der move um zu sagen wir hören auf das spieler
feedback feedback und pushen den release back ich könnte mir vorstellen aber ich
glaube nicht dass sie sich des weihnachts weihnachtsstells entgehen
lassen inside google data center das haben wir schon mal angeguckt do not do
this je nachdem was das ist es ist überhaupt kein
problem das zu machen warum auch immer ich das nicht nicht tun soll
das ist aber einfach nur dass das thumbnail mehr klick klickbar wird
noch uns verhefelt hat er nicht tales verwendet hat es noch nicht tales beworben
das ist wieder typische kokona typisches typisches kokona video wir sägen
einfach die wand auf
jambas barbo das haben wir schon mal geguckt irgendwann ich glaube das haben
wir schon mal zusammen geguckt aufstieg und fall des jambas barbos ich glaube
das haben wir schon mal zusammen geguckt kommt mir bekannt vor das video auf
jeden fall
so youtube empfehlung sind heute wieder richtig pepega gibt es nix
oder nicht
was das
wieder was von dem typ vielleicht vielleicht ich machs mal kurz ich mach
mal kurz als tepp auf so als bevor wir jetzt anfangen wie ich habe noch ein
paar videos vor letzter woche auf ein paar neue videos bevor bevor wir anfangen
wir lassen uns wir lassen uns erst noch mal eine runde eine runde von level
cap g bade einfach wir müssen wir müssen uns immer eine runde von level cap
schippe in lassen mix reaction kann man wohl so sagen ja wenn windows 11 sagt
dass tpm nicht aktiv ist muss in einem bios gehen und gucken ob das
eingeschaltet ist wenn nicht musst du das hier machen
microsoft zeigt trick zur umgehung der windows 11 anforderungen wenn das nicht
geht also jedes mal wenn ich was von call of duty vanguard höre ich habe jetzt
also ich dachte die also muss jetzt mal sagen wie es bisher war bisher muss sagen
ich habe immer was von call of duty vanguard gehört habe ich mir gedacht
juckt mich überhaupt nicht juckt mich null es ist wirklich minus eins das
interesse natürlich habe ich ab und zu mal ein paar sachen zu geguckt hat mich
null gejuckt und ich dachte mir die ganze zeit immer ach wie schön dass mal
wieder modernes battle field rauskommt so nachdem ich jetzt die battle field 20
42 beta gespielt habe denke ich mir eher dass wir diesmal einen wettrennen wenn
er schlechtere game rausbringen kann kann man so sagen die lack of polish bugs
ja das ist auch so was das sagt es sagen die leute bei mir unter den videos auch
so nach dem motto aber max dies hat doch gesagt dass wir bald wieder wird bei
release alles anders ich denke ich wäre mal absolut wird wird schämt
wisst ihr ich sage auch morgen kommt ein neues video und kommt morgen neues video
wahrscheinlich nicht also da ist sagt auch viel wenn der tag lang ist
heiligste nach gering xp für passenger kills will get fixed for launch there
will be extra features like colored lights on soldiers to help distinguish
friendlies from enemies at launch the m5 rocket launcher was so one hit kill
air vehicles at launch and a handful of other war nicht agil genug of proper
scoreboard and expanded map are also being addressed they are currently track
die hätten mal mehr blockchain machen müssen
king some specific technical issues blockchain löst alles in der ja they just
updated blockchain blockchain löst sogar die die par die die ausweis app die hat
ohne blockchain hat es nicht funktioniert mit blockchain ja auch nicht
potentially trigger people with photosensitivity concerns controller
keybinds causing weapons to autofire or preventing menu inputs from working is
also being looked at for now it seems like the solution is to unbind all
controller inputs now many of the issues with the beta do stand out like a sore
thumb either dice has a lot of work left to do before launch or the developers
really have updated and fixed many of the current issues in the haben garantiert
2042 die haben garantiert vieles gefixt aber die grundlegenden entscheidungen die
sie getroffen haben sind teilweise also sie sind tief im game drin und teilweise
fragwürdig die wendet guck mal dass man bots einbaut und bots im vorfeld
bewirbt das ist nix wo die jetzt sagen ach wir haben sonst anders überlegt
obwohl es einfach wäre das rauszuschmeißen es wird garantiert so
bleiben gut natürlich kannst du dann auf jeden custom server spielen mit
deaktiviertem bot aber allein schon dass man auf die idee gekommen ist dass das
was gutes ist finde ich merkwürdig und wenn das was wir bei
dewey gerade spielen die beste map ist ja dann eh gute nacht
multiple dice developers have said the beta doesn't have all the fixes and
optimisations that they've already implemented but even if all of the
technical problems have been addressed stuff like specialist the limited
destruction and vehicle controls are concerned it is however worth mentioning
that every battlefield beta has been more or less a mess and dice rarely
launched the evil cookie das ist auch so ein ding das kann ich mir auch nicht so
genau erklären klar klar man braucht ein bisschen vorbereitung auf so einen
spielertest wenn wird nicht die absolute pleading edge version ausrollen mit
sachen drin die unfertig komplett unfertig sind mit platzhalter texturen und
was auch immer alles das wird man wahrscheinlich nicht machen schon ein
paar das ist ein paar wochen hinten dran ist dass man das auf irgendeinen
halbwegs spielbaren stand bringen kann verstehe ich doch aber dass das angeblich
uralt ist wird kein sinn ergeben wenn das neue doch so viel besser ist
weil wir die surfer testen
experience let us know what you think dies have to improve before lunch are you
worried the beta might represent the games long die machen einfach kein
daily scrum weiß bei da ist ich glaube daran liegt sie sind nicht agil genug
auch kann auch keine tribe meetings kein daily scrum keine try ob die überhaupt
in zertifizierten scrum master haben meint ihr da ist hat ein zertifizierten
scrum master ich ich ich fürchte nicht dass dann sonst wäre das nicht passiert
zertified scrum und lean und agil und safe sind die auch nicht das kann
nichts werden das geht nicht die folgen die die
folgen nicht aktuellen software management best practices das kann nicht
funktionieren und außerdem haben sie prinzipiell viel zu wenig blockchain
bewirbt sich doch als bei da ist als krumbas da ganz sicher den da ist er
letting an leave moment point da ist jobs
was besuchen ist einfach mal open positions da ist
zeige ja join us at da ist
open positions alles klar okay wir haben uns art director cinematic team sind
nur der level art scene lightning technolast artist developer development
director zene development director narrative writer game designer gameplay
der jw i visual scripter und es ist ein producer
denn ja er geht er man ks c++ software engineer jetzt jetzt weiß ich warum das
sagt das spiel jetzt ist es mir jetzt ist mir alles klar
ich wusste dass frostball zum größten teil c++ ist aber jetzt sieht man es hier
noch mal ist es kein wunder senior research engineer deep learning für die
bots wahrscheinlich bestimmt software engineer im test technical director audio
software engineer online software engineer online cc plus plus wahrscheinlich
eher klar wahrscheinlich auch eher netzwerk anti cheat cloud course software
engineer renderings auf c++ frostbite frostbite seht ihr leute die suchen die
suchen keinen agilen scrum master das ist das problem wir haben es
identifiziert die hätten uns mal fragen sollen twitch chat consulting cute chat
consulting die hätten uns mal fragen sollen wir uns ist sofort klar woran
das liegt da fehlt der senior agile lean safe scrum master mit blockchain
dann wäre das gleich viel besser gelaufen bei da ist ja verkackt da ist
würde ich sagen einfach verkackt
wenn ich mit der zeit geht geht mit der zeit sagt man so schön
ok weiter in the comments below call of duty warzone got its latest seasonal
update and it's temporarily introduced warzone players discovered the stg 44
and m1 gerand in the games menus and we're able to dice müsste eigentlich den
ganzen chat einstellen mindestens und so wenig kripto meiner ganz klar was
wengard abhekt und prägt die game sekunde das erweckt er den anschein
das erweckt er den anschein als ist warzone nicht broken also immer jedes
mal wenn ich wieder mal überlege ah guckst du dir mal wieder ein bisschen
warzone an und ein bisschen rumschaue ist eigentlich das geschrei groß dass es
letztletzte update wieder irgendwelche game breaking dinger rein gebracht hat
das von unsichtbaren models bis gegner die du dann nicht siehst ach was auch
immer da immer ist das ist das ist laufend irgendwas in warzone so dass ich
spiele
Vanguards Waffen bekommen
Vorzonen haben ich das verstanden aktuell gibt es 5 Attachments und wenn Gott kriegt 10 wie wollen die dann 10 Attachments an eine warfe machen
Watte her wie soll das aussehen ist das deine Pistole die irgendwie sich in den lmg transformiert oder was weapons can only equip 5
Attachments vanguard weapons getting double that opens in vier Scopes nebeneinander
Red Dot
Ich stelle es mir gerade so vor du machst einfach eine Waffe die hat nebeneinander
Die hat hier Red Dot
Dann nehmen hat sie irgendwie den ACOG
Dann nehmen hat sie irgendwie keine ahnung draufgemaut und irgendwo ein achtfaches Scope, dann habe ich wieder ein 16x Scope
Du kannst einfach von links nach rechts durchgucken
Bescheid durchkommen
Ja das will man ja das will man ja das will mein
ück obrigado
Verkaufen
a
Merz
providing
Wer hätte das gedacht, dass die Microtransactions an Mann bringen wollen oder an die Frau, hätt ich ja nie mit gerechnet. Ganz was Neues.
Der Name ist schon wieder.
Was? Oh Mann, warum? Warum machen die immer so Dinge? Lass doch das Original Game da. Lass doch einfach das Original Game da.
Wer das Original Game spielen will, soll das Original Game spielen. Wer das Neue spielen will, soll das Neue spielen.
Was ist das immer für ein Schwachsinn? Das ging mir auch schon bei Warcraft 3 voll auf den Sack. Lass das Original Game einfach da.
Ja, genau. War Diablo 2 so glücklich? Nee, Warcraft 3 war das doch so. Hast du Warcraft 3 Reforge nicht automatisch bekommen, wenn du Warcraft 3 schon hattest?
War da nicht irgendwas? Oder bringe ich es jetzt durcheinander?
Die meisten benutzen das Ding doch eh, um VR-Porn zu gucken. Ich habe keine Statistik, aber ich gehe mal stark von Haus.
Ich habe keine VR-Brille, das liegt daran, weil das einzige VR-Game, was ich spielen will, Half-Life Alex ist. Und ich sehe es nicht ein, mir das für ein Game zu kaufen.
Hat man sowas mieten? Bestimmt. Bestimmt.
Destiny juckt mich so überhaupt nicht.
Aber ich glaube, die Spielerzahlen sind relativ gut. Ist Destiny 2 auf Steam jetzt? Ups. Mittlerweile schon, glaube ich. Destiny 2 ist Steam. Die sind ja weg von Blizzard.
Wir sind nur die Spielerzahlen, zeigt mal her. Ja, das ist nicht schlecht. Das ist nicht schlecht. Knapp 100.000 Spieler aktuell picken, das ist nicht schlecht.
Was sind da aktuell oben? CS? Dota? Gut. Wundert mich nicht. New World? Da bin ich gespannt. Meine Aussage von vor zwei Wochen steht noch.
Mal gucken, wir gucken es uns das nächste Jahr an. Es geht aber schon runter. Es ist schon, aber das ist ja normal. Aber es geht schon runter.
Apex? Pupke? Pupke, immer noch so ein Ding. Das hört man kaum noch was von. Aber scheint mir jetzt relativ, hier war der Hype, hier war der Mega Hype, scheint ja relativ konstant zu sein hier.
Pupke? Naraka? Playpoint? Das ist irgend so ein Weep? MMO oder sowas. Hab ich mal in einem Stream zugesehen. Team Fortress, das ist auch ein Game, das hält sich einfach für immer. Team Fortress 2. Team Fortress 2 bekommt keine Updates mehr seit irgendwie 500 Jahren.
Aber das Spiel ist immer noch. Wobei letztens gab es doch wieder ein Update. Oder Valve hat gesagt, sie wollen es noch mal updaten oder irgendwas. Was war deine Aussage zu New World?
Dass viele Leute, die jetzt das Spiel spielen, aktuell noch gar nicht wissen, dass es eigentlich kein Game für sie ist. Bei New World werden nur die Leute bleiben, die dieses Faction Base PvP mögen auf Dauer. Und die meisten MMO-Spieler sind das eben nicht. Die wissen es bloß noch nicht.
Wir gucken uns das in, wir gucken uns das nächstes Jahr an. Nächstes Jahr, Januar, Februar. Und ich predicte einfach, dass mindestens die Hälfte der Spieler weg ist, wenn nicht noch deutlich mehr. Und die ersten Server zusammen gelegt werden. Februar, so rum. Kann natürlich auch vollkommen falsch liegen. Aber ich glaube es nicht.
Wenn es nicht gerade den PC grillt, das ist ein Grafikkartenproblem, das hat nichts mit New World zu tun. Könnte ja in einem anderen Game auch passieren. Problematisch ist die New World halt nur, weil die Leute in der Warteschlange sind mit uncapped FPS.
Ok, hier ist Destiny. Warframe ist auch noch angesagt. Wallpaper Engine. Die Beta. Warum ist die... Moment, ist die auf Steam? Ich wusste gar nicht, dass Battlefield auf Steam ist. Ich habe es auf Origin gekauft. Bin ich dumm? Hätte ich es mal über Steam gespielt? Ich kann noob.
Hätte ich das mal über Steam gemacht? Wobei, ich konnte den Code nur in Origin einlösen. Hätte ich mir das mal hier geholt, Mensch? Naja, gut. Vorbei. Steam braucht Origin. Ah, das ist wieder so die typische Geschichte. Battlefield, genauso wie bei den anderen Battlefield. Es launcht Origin und dann launcht es an. Nein, nein, das ist auch egal.
Wo sage ich Roblox? Roblox ist nicht auf Steam, oder? Roblox. Das ist ihr eigener Kram. Microsoft Store, alles klar. Ok, wir gucken mal weiter. Destiny juckt mich eh nicht.
Ja. Hackamans.
Ja, wenn der... Also ganz ehrlich, wer davon surprised ist, verstehe ich nicht. Selbstverständlich verdienst du krass viel Geld, wenn du irgendwie 20.000 plus Zuschauer hast.
Natürlich, alles andere wäre ja auch irgendwie witzlos. Stellt euch nochmal vor, wenn die absoluten Top-Streamer, davon gibt es vielleicht 20 weltweit, wenn die nicht damit reich werden, dann wird ja niemand damit reich.
Also das ist im Vergleich zu anderen Top-End-Entertainment-Branchen wahrscheinlich nichts, was die verdienen. Und natürlich kommen noch Sponsorings und alles dabei, das wird bei weitem nicht das einzige sein, aber ganz ehrlich, das ist der Witz.
Und in der Einliste war ich auch in den Top-6.000, aber dann hat sich rausgestellt, sie haben sich verrechnet und jetzt bin ich nicht mehr in den Top-6.000, was auch eher hinkommt. Aber trotzdem, wenn man sich mal anguckt, wie weit das runtergeht.
Und im Mittelfeld hast du Leute, die haben, der Verdienst ist ja nicht in einem Jahr gewesen, das war ja quasi seit diesem Dokument 2019, also 2 Jahre. Und da gibt es Leute, die haben halt im Mittelfeld, die verdienen halt in 2 Jahren 100k über Twitch.
Davon wirst du nicht reich. Das sind 50.000€ und du musst das ja auch noch versteuern. Das sind 50.000€ im Jahr. Klar, kommt dann bestimmt noch ein bisschen Sponsoring und alles dazu. Ich gehe davon aus, die können halbwegs gut davon leben.
Aber das war es auch. Also es ist nicht so krass, wie es sich manche vorstellen und man sieht es auch wieder. Du musst echt zu den absoluten Top, also ziemlich weit oben sein, dass du davon nicht einfach nur gut leben kannst, sondern auch nur ansatzweise so was wie reich wirst mit Twitch.
Also das ist nicht so, wie sich das manche vorstellen. Das hat das wieder gezeigt. Und wer da überrascht von ist, der hat, glaube ich, sich nie ernsthaft damit beschäftigt.
Mit normaler Arbeit kann man einfacher Geld verdienen. Ja, das ist tatsächlich so. Auch wenn es oftmals nicht so wirkt. Aber ja, das ist so. Und entspannter. Und entspannter. Gut, je nach Arbeit natürlich.
Und entspannter. Weil man muss sagen, bei Twitch, du bist komplett selbst verantwortlich für alles. Also jetzt mal von Toss und sonstigen Sachen ausgehen. Du bist quasi selbstständig.
Du musst dich selbst darum kümmern. Um alles. Und dafür sorgen, dass es weiterhin läuft. Und du musst auch Content machen, wenn es dir schlecht geht, wenn du keinen Bock hast.
Wenn irgendwas trauriges in deinem Leben passiert ist und du jetzt am liebsten zwei Wochen flennen willst. So übertrieben gesagt. Nein, du musst dann deinen Stream anmachen und sag hey, funny fortnite.
Oder was auch immer. Du hast keinen krass gelitten. Das ist, also es ist, glaube ich, nicht so rosig, wie sich das einige vorstellen.
Wo wir übrigens gerade dabei sind, wusstet ihr schon, dass man mit einem Prime-Sub einen Streamer seiner Wahl einmal im Monat kostenlos unterstützen kann?
Ich glaube, das ist sicherlich neu für viele Leute. Und nachdem das neu ist für so viele Leute, wollen wir das bestimmt jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Und nachdem ihr gerade bei mir im Stream seid, biete ich mich natürlich selbstlos an dafür, dass ihr das mal bei mir ausprobieren könnt. So, next. Nein, ich mach keinen funny fortnite.
Und was auch witzig war bei diesem Twitch-Leak, was auch witzig war, dass so viele Streamer gesagt haben, oh, langweilig, interessiert mich nicht.
Siehste, die Abo-Falle klappt immer. Danke für die Subs, Leute. Die Abo-Falle klappt immer.
Willkommen hier am Start. Er ist ein Tischlbackus. Ihr habt mich doch richtig vorgelesen. 0212s4zcxgv. Ich weiß nicht, wie ich das aussprechen soll, aber wird schon passen.
Brooklyn. Markepo. Excess. Das hört sich fast an wie ein Apple-Produkt. Danke für die Subs, Leute. th-man87. Pog, ihr habt jetzt alle damit einen Keks in Holz bekommen.
Und für alle, die, oh, hier, 20 Monate. DarkoXTV. 20 Monate. Pog, du bist so lang schon am Start. Das ist ja richtig Hyper-Subscription hier.
Da sieht man wieder, es gibt auch Leute, die sind nicht so aktiv im Chat, aber permanent dabei. Ist auch nice, dass es so Leute gibt.
Zumindest, mir sagt der Name aus dem Chat wenig, aber 20 Monate. Massive Subscription hier. Fabi281. Danke für den Sub. MarkNCS. Bam.
Also, wir haben ja übrigens, wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, wir haben neue Sub-Batches. Der erste Monat ist der Keks in Holz. Der zweite Monat ist der Keks in Original-Farbe.
Der nächste Monat ist der Keks in Silber. Den haben wir jetzt hier irgendwo nicht. Doch, hier, hier ist der Keks in Silber. Danach bekommt ihr den Keks, ab 6 Monaten bekommt ihr den Keks in Diamant.
Und ab einem Jahr kriegt ihr den Keks im Haftbefehlung. In Gold. Ja, ich weiß, Diamant und Gold ist vertauscht, aber ich finde den Gold-Keks einfach besser mit der Kette. Das ist nicer.
Leute, danke für die ganzen Subs. Mango Kiesel. Arrow D. Massive Subs hier. Bitte schön, Leute.
Oh, hier, das Gamtrain ist auch am Start. Und ab zwei Jahren, ja, ab zwei Jahren kriegst du auch weiter den Gold-Keks. Ich habe aber noch mehr. Ich habe nicht nur Gold-Keks, ich habe noch, beispielsweise, einen mit Hut. Den finde ich auch ganz cool.
Ich habe mir überlegt, ob ich nicht den Gold-Keks mit Hut mache. Natürlich mit Fedora-Hut ab zwei Jahren. Ich muss mal gucken. Ich habe noch Bronze, ich habe noch Eisen, ich habe noch mit Stirnband.
Wobei ich den mit Stirnband nicht nehmen will. Der sieht fast so aus wie der Avatar vom Lost, was er da gemalt hat. Ich habe noch ein paar andere Sachen.
Ich habe noch ein paar andere Sachen. Ich muss mal gucken, was es ab zwei Jahren gibt. Aktuell gibt es ab zwei Jahren noch nichts. Es bleibt beim Keks in Gold.
Wann BF mit Lost? Es gibt Battlefield Beta ist down. Ich habe den Lost gefragt, ob wir was zur Beta aufnehmen wollen. Hat bis jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht gesehen. Ich denke mal zu Release, machen wir da auf jeden Fall noch irgendwas zusammen.
Keks, gucken wir mal weiter. Ach ja, stimmt, was ich noch sagen wollte. Was ich auch nicht verstanden habe bei dem Twitch, dass die Streamer... Alter, Ende die Beta nicht um neun. Ja, die Beta ist vorbei.
Beta ist rum. Also, dass die ganzen Streamer da so gelassen waren, das kann ich gar nicht verstehen. Und ich rede jetzt nicht etwa von, dass man weiß, was sie verdienen. Das hätte mich jetzt persönlich auch nicht so großartig interessiert, ob das jetzt irgendwie richtig geleakt ist oder nicht. Das ist ja geleakt, das jucke ich nicht.
Was mich viel mehr jucken würde, ist, was da eventuell sonst noch alles geleakt ist. Das würde mich gerade an der Stelle der großen Streamer deutlich mehr jucken. Aber irgendwie hat das jeder verdrängt, keine Ahnung.
Ja, das habe ich gesehen. Es gab Leaks für Moderator, so Moderator Guides, wie was gemacht wird. Die haben tatsächlich irgendwie fünf Seiten, welche Beleidigungen und Flüche und sonstige Sachen tostwürdig, bannwürdig sind.
Also, wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise mal einen Battlefield 3 Soldat zitiere, Zitat, I get fucked up in the ass over here, dann ist das sicherlich schon laut Twitch, zumindest schwulenfeindlich, wenn nicht sogar irgendwie bannwürdig.
Da musst du aufpassen auf Twitch. Aber nachdem ich ja nur Battlefield 3 Voice Samples zitiere, sollte das hoffentlich okay sein.
Toast. Gibt es auch eine Whitelist für Alenity zeigt ihren Körpershit? Bestimmt. Bestimmt. Wenn ich mir überlege, wie viele auf der Bananenrutschgrills noch am Start sind, bestimmt. Wobei zumindest Indie Fox ist ja mittlerweile weg.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich weil Estrin vorkommt. Was ich viel heftiger fand, was der Fabian damals alles erzählt hat, so für Sprüche, als ich mit ihm öfters gespielt habe.
Das wäre auf Twitch auch schon teilweise richtig Toast. Du darfst heute bestimmt auch nicht mehr sagen hier.
Fick dich weg, du Hobo-Fürst. Sonst gastriere ich dir die Eier.
Das ist bestimmt auch schon Toast.
Echt, ist die weg? Wirklich?
Oh, da muss jetzt aber das Only-Fans-Game aufgedreht werden.
Ich bin schon seit einem Jahr relativ aktiv wieder. Mal gucken, ob das so bleibt.
Ich gucke selten bei ihm rein, aber würde er heute manchmal Sachen vom Stapel lassen, die er in den alten Videos erzählt hat, dann wäre auch Monka-Toast-Twitch der Twitch-Bannfinger am Start.
Und ich meine jetzt nicht, 12 war immer im Whirlpool nacheinander gebankt, sondern eher andere Sprüche.
Ich glaube, das ist nicht bannwürdig, aber andere Sachen, die er gebracht hat.
Ich persönlich finde es nicht weiter wild. Man hat eindeutig gesehen, dass das quasi so eine Art, Rollplay kann man es nicht nennen, aber so ein Online-Character mäßig war. Wobei ich nicht weiß, ob er nicht in echt auch so rumflamed. Kein Schimmer.
Ob es eine Parodie war, weiß ich nicht. Ich glaube, da steckt schon relativ viel von ihm persönlich drin. Aber man sollte das Ganze jetzt nicht überbewerten.
Naja, aber das hat mich bei dem ganzen Twitch-League mehr gewundert, dass es keinen von den Streamern gejuckt hat.
Das wäre definitiv, da finde ich, da hat er es auch teilweise wirklich übertrieben, aber das wäre heute nicht mehr drin. Null.
Ja, weiß nicht, ob es die Videos eigentlich noch online gibt.
Wusstet ihr eigentlich, dass er damals sein Channel löschen wollte? Weil er Angst hatte, dass die Leute verklagen? Das war echt...
Also in der heutigen Zeit, wenn das die falschen Leute auf Twitter mitbekommen hätten, dieses Video, dann wäre der Shitstorm am Laufen, sage ich euch.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal das Video fertig.
Twitter hat mich übrigens übelst debatet. Ich habe im Vorfeld schon mal, also direkt nachdem der League rausgekommen ist, habe ich mein Passwort geändert und mein Streamkey geändert.
Und was macht Twitter zwei Tage später? Sie ändern den Streamkey nochmal, weil sie gesagt haben, für die Sicherheit für euch und ich habe mich schon gewundert, warum man Stream nicht angeht.
Narrative Experiences. Man könnte auch sagen, irgendwas mit Story.
Das heißt, man kann nicht nur Maps bauen, sondern auch Skripte, irgendwelche Trigger reinbauen oder sonst was.
Oh, ich muss mal gucken, ob sich der Cutter gemeldet hat. Ich habe doch einen Cutter angeschrieben, ob der meine Battlefield-Streams irgendwie mal so ein 10-Minuten-Highlight-Video draus basteln kann.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall cool, so als Überbrückung bis zum Release.
Warum nicht?
Aber warum?
Jetzt mit Raytracing.
Ich meine, wenn man sich das hier anguckt, gerade mal so hier auch Geometrie und sowas, Quake 2 ist glaube ich von 1997?
Also das ist 23 Jahre alt ungefähr, Quake 2. Da hat sich schon echt was getan die letzten 23 Jahre, wenn man sich das hier mal im Vergleich anguckt.
Aber das meiste hat sich getan in den ersten 10 Jahren. Es hat sich danach auch noch viel getan, gerade dass die detailreichen Sachen noch detaillierter und realistischer geworden sind.
Aber wenn du dir die Spiele anguckst, sag mal mal von 2015 zu jetzt, da hat sich nicht so viel getan wie von hier bis 2015.
Aber es ist schon hart, da hat sich wirklich verdammt viel getan.
Na dann.
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt an? Battlefield 3? Nein, nein, wir gucken jetzt keine Battlefield 3 an. Wir bleiben noch mal ganz kurz bei Battlefield 2042. Ich will nämlich mal gucken, ob deine Battlefield Top...
Most Incredible Moments Beta.
Das will ich mir jetzt noch mal angucken. Top Plays der Battlefield Beta.
Oder wollen wir erst was anderes gucken und dann das?
Aber ich glaube nicht, wir gucken jetzt erstmal das an.
Bin ich nämlich mal gespannt, was die anderen nicht Boomer-Players für Top Plays haben.
Noobtube, den habe ich legit nicht einmal ausgerüstet.
Ja gut, der macht jetzt einen Achter-Kill oder so da drin. Einfach Nades rein spammen.
Das kann ja in dem Tunnel passieren. Deswegen sage ich ja auch, das ist der Selbstmord-Tunnel. Es gibt halt keine Flank-Möglichkeiten in dem Spiel.
Und das wenn es fertig ist. Seriously? Oh nice. Cool. Oh, Pog. Pog.
Das war cool.
Zack, was war da jetzt das Top-Play dran? Das habe ich nicht verstanden. Low IQ. 4K, passt. Was war da jetzt das Top-Play dran?
Ah, der hat, man sieht es kaum, der hat drei Leute gekillt. Man sieht das kaum. Die Quali ist so schlecht. Der hat drei Leute mit dem Crappling-Hook da raus gekillt.
Ah, das sind Cormorants. Ja, das muss natürlich sein. Das muss natürlich sein.
Bam. Bam. Oh. Pace. Pace-Time. Alter.
Dazu, Sekunde, Sekunde. Moment, Moment, Moment. Ich brauche die richtige Untermalung dafür. Ich weiß noch nicht, wo ich mein Emote habe. Ah, wo ist es hier?
Oh, oh mein Gott. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Das war schon richtig Face-I Scopes, Alter.
Face I ghostsiler
Zités, jawoll
Ver판 ka
Z至 ja, weil
Und weg damit
Ich seh nix
Oh, der Selbstmordtunnel wieder
Alter, hier wird aber, hier wird aber hart äh rausgehobt
Der Commentator hört sich immer so wahnsinnig begeistert an
Das ist truly incredible
Und tschuuu, jawoll, sei so
Oh nee, man sieht nix, da ist doch nix
Ah doch, dahinten ist tatsächlich was
Sehr laut
Was alles kann, was, was, Massive Game, Massive Game
Was auch witzig ist, wir machen jetzt Werbung für was, was in der Beta nicht drin ist, aber
dann eben ein fertiges Spiel sein wird und auch ganz tolles
Ich würde da auch really forward zu looken, wenn ich gesponsert werde
Also würden die sagen, Max, wir geben dir 2000 Euro und du sagst, dass du really forward
looks zu diesem Feature, das hat ich kein Problem mit, easy sellout, mach ich
Ich würde, ey, wenn ein VPN Dienst zu mir kommen würde und damit okay ist, dass ich
mal ein Video gemacht hab, dass die zum größten Teil alle Scheiße erzählen und sagen, Max,
wir geben dir 2000 Euro, sag unser VPN ist gut, dann sag ich auch, das VPN ist gut, interessiert
mich nicht
Einfach, ich würde dann halt nicht sagen, ich benutze es, ich bin da komplett von überzeugt,
ich würde das so machen, wie das beispielsweise der Bauer immer macht in seinen Videos, so
nach dem Motto, ich lese euch einfach die geilsten Sachen vor vom Hersteller und gut
ist, fertig
Wenn ich was mache, wie beispielsweise mit Hetzner, und was ist, was ich selbst benutze
und selbst davon überzeugt bin, auch selbst ohne Sponsoring benutzen würde, dann ist
es was anderes, aber anpreisen, aus meiner Sicht, wenn ich nicht davon überzeugt bin
oder es ich nicht benutze, mach ich nicht, aber ich hab überhaupt keine Probleme, was
zu einem Produkt zu erzählen, aber solange ich nicht erzählen muss, ich benutze das und
finde es super geil, sondern einfach nur, was daran halt eben die Vorzüge sind, im Prinzip
ist es halt nichts anderes, wie Werbung für einen Hersteller, was willst du machen, wenn
kommt das letzte Hetzner Video, warum das letzte, du meinst das nächste, gibt erstmal
kein letztes
oder Montag, Montag weißt du da mehr als ich
Ne ne, ihr habt 3 Teile zu dem, zu diesem einen Thema, danach gibt es ein neues Thema
Bam, dieser Chat ist deutsch
Ah, ich wollte gerade sagen, die üben wie kann man dem Heli an einer vorbei schießen
oder, das trifft, das trifft, das trifft ihn nicht, die trifft, Bam, fuck
sind schon ein paar coole Sachen dabei, die Dinge halten auch übelst viel aus, würde
zu viel Damage zu machen, lol, was ist denn das, was ist das für ne Quali, ich wusste
gar nicht, dass es auf der Wii rauskommt, ah, trotzdem nice, jetzt wisst ihr auch warum
ich sag, das ist der Selbstbordtunnel, du kannst da nicht durch, du kannst im Prinzip
nur durch den Tunnel dich killen lassen oder übers Feld und dich killen lassen, es braucht
mindestens noch 2 weitere Tunnels, dass du ordentlich flanken kannst und das ganze muss
auch ein bisschen mehr nach, da muss ein bisschen mehr Objekte hin, ok, der Heli will abgeschossen
werden oder, ich dachte erst, das ist sein Gehirn, ich dachte der wollte Five Head Emote
nachmachen, ist es gar nicht, das sind die Haare, nice und Heli, Heli, Heli, Heli, zack
oh, oh der fliegt auf den Chat, bamm, war klar, als ich den Chat ins Bild fliegen hab, sehen
wir klar, Predicted, Predicted, oh, oh, es lag nicht bei euch, es lag überall, zack,
nice, das ist einfach durchgegangen, das ist einfach durch, als hättet ihr keine Hitbox,
nice, nice, LMG legit, da stehen sie einfach nur rum, Leute, wo waren diese Gegner gestern
im Stream, wo waren die, ich musste gestern alle 2 Sekunden sliden um die Ecke und mich
verstecken, dass ich nicht abgeaimt wurde von 50 Billionen Gegnern, na gut, vorgestern
im Stream hatten wir auch schon viele Noobs, also man muss sagen, gestern war mit Abstand
der schwitzigste Tag in der Beta, es war echt anstrengend gestern, die Tage davor war easy
mode, boah, das ist OPRF, ja, Airbrake, und jetzt, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
Airbrake, und jetzt, ok, geht einfach durch die Flares durch oder wie, ok, jetzt weiß
ich auch, warum ich nie, warum ich nie einen Jett gekillt hat, damit was zu killen ist
ja, Gericht, Pepega, ok, jetzt geht's, habe ich gesagt, ich finde es ja interessant, dass
in Battlefield irgendwie Jets und so Raketenexplosionen aushalten, normalerweise sind die recht fragil,
was so was angeht, hast du ein Gewaltgespiel, ja, die Beta, ich werde es nicht spielen im
Confederate, aber es wäre einfach speaking out von Mm is rainin fin, sizes inside, in
Baumeisters, warum ist es durchgegangen, ditze khain genau, reason to be low rise, wow,
oh ho ho, poggers poggers poggers und jetzt runter, sehr cool, sehr nice, das klappt zwar
Einmal von 50 Versuchen
Die Leute haben mir gesagt, dass Sniper im Jahr 2042 wirklich zufrieden ist.
Während es ein paar Dinge gibt, die sie sich verändern wollen,
gibt es sicherlich...
Also, was zufrieden am Snipern in diesem Spiel ist, oder generell was zufrieden ist,
ist der Headshot-Sound, dieses Bling.
Ich glaube es war aber, den ähnlichen Sound gab es ja in Battlefield 5 auch schon.
Also, wenn du jemanden headshots und es macht einfach Bling, das ist zufrieden.
Ja, aber ansonsten...
Das sind meine liebsten Sniper-Klips, die ich in die Hand gegeben habe,
Including that really lucky and accurate collateral while being on the Zipwire.
Das war gut.
Ah, da liegt einer, ich sehe ihn ja.
Das ist Playstation jetzt, oder?
Das ist Playstation?
Das ist PC auf jeden Fall.
Die ganzen Sniper-Dudes, Mensch, nice.
Zack, in the cop.
Next, in the cop.
Next, jawoll.
Ahh, was kann das sein?
Massive, nice.
Nice.
Poggers.
Jetzt gibt es.
Ok, das war nur so half predicted.
Ich sehe nichts.
Ich sehe... Wo ist da was?
Hä?
War das Setup?
Das war bestimmt Setup.
Bam, jawoll.
Ich sehe da nichts.
Alter, wo ist da was?
Was?
Ok, das ist einfach random in die Richtung geschossen.
Ok, den sehe ich jetzt, ganz klein.
Der ist auch schon irgendwie ok.
Die Bewegung von den Helis ist auch noch total kaputt.
Das fühlt sich ein bisschen an wie auf Schienen.
Guckt euch das an.
Oder wird es gebashed?
Guck mal, wie das Ding keiner wegkriegt.
Alles schon krasser Play.
Ja, da gibt es viel zu wenig.
Ok, das ist schon krass.
Ok.
Ja, da gibt es viel zu wenig.
10 Euro, danke für den Zapp.
Stimmt.
Das Ding nennt sich ja C5 in dem Spiel.
Was?
Warum auch mal?
Hat eigentlich einer eine Ahnung, warum die Waffen nicht realistisch...
Also klar, die Dinger heißen M5A3, ne?
Aktuell sind wir bei M4A1 und so.
Aber das 2042 werden sicherlich noch Waffen verwendet,
die 2021 gerade eingeführt wurden.
Die wollen keine Waffenlizenzen kaufen, oder?
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
In dem vergangenen Spiel haben sie es immer gemacht.
Und ich finde es auch schon in Cold War und in Modern Warfare war das auch so.
Ich finde es einfach doof, wenn die Dinger nicht den richtigen Namen haben.
Sie bekommen mehr, als sie sich mit diesem tollen Klub verabschieden.
Da ist einer, der ist in meiner Kamera.
Was passiert da jetzt?
Er ist hier.
Das ist ein Havoc.
Ich sehe ihn.
Er ist weit.
Das ist für eine Sprache.
Der kleine ist hier.
Er ist hier.
Ich sehe ihn, ich sehe ihn.
Auf, auf, auf.
Drohne, Drohne, Drohne.
Bam.
Nice.
Das ist cool, wenn sowas klappt.
Das ist das, was Battlefield mit ausmacht.
Erstmal schon T-Baggen.
Ich weiß, dass es ein Beta ist, also werde ich nicht auf alle Buggen im Spiel konzentrieren.
Ich habe ein paar witzige Buggen, die definitiv wert zu teilen sind.
Das ist ja nice.
Erstmal explodiert, aber es fliegt weiter.
Who cares, dass ich kaputt bin?
Das macht keinen Unterschied.
Das fliegt so wie auf Schienen, das Zeug.
Wow.
Boris.
Das habe ich nicht geschafft.
Ich habe es nicht hinbekommen, mich auf die Spitze zu hooken.
Und ich sehe, es haben wohl noch mehr probiert.
Hä? Was jetzt?
Ist das in der Rakete drin oder was?
Nice.
Fuck.
Ja, gleich ist er out of map.
Bezos-Poff.
Captain Kirk-Poff, der fliegt doch jetzt auch auf die ISS.
Mit 90, Alter.
Ich würde jetzt nicht freiwillig ins Weltall fliegen, aber mit 90 erst recht nicht.
Fuck.
Ja, waren schon coole Sachen dabei.
Die Musik ist bestimmt Monka Toss.
Da höre ich... Hallo?
Okay, Browser.
Hallo, meine Taskleiste ist broken.
Jetzt geht es wieder.
Meine Taskleiste ist einfach kaputt.
Windows, Windows, Alter.
Okay, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
Far Cry 6, ja, going 100 Sekunden, was haben wir?
Kannst du deinen Bewusstsein auf einen Computer sprechen?
Kurz gesagt, macht immer nice Videos.
Was ich beim letzten kurz gesagt Video schon witzig fand, was wir geguckt haben.
Die gesagt haben, terraforming Venus.
So, it might be easier than you think.
Und dann ging es im Prinzip 15 Minuten darüber, dass es eigentlich gar nicht richtig möglich ist.
Viel easier als ich gedacht habe.
Gucken wir jetzt.
Far Cry 3, going 100 Sekunden.
Das Styropor-Video welches?
Wo ist ein Styropor-Video?
Was meinst du?
Ich sehe da nichts.
Oder meinst du das, was du geschickt hast?
Das sind 26 Minuten, das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Moin Chat, ein 7400 CPU entspricht nicht dem Minimalanfall und glaubt ihr, dass du...
Ja, kannst du, so schlecht ist das Ding glaube ich gar nicht.
Das wird schon funktionieren.
Wenn die dich nicht anderweitig blocken, wird das funktionieren.
Ja, ja, das geht, das geht schon.
Das funktioniert.
Ist halt die Frage, ob sie nicht das Spiel lassen.
Aber wenn wird es funktionieren, solange du eine halbwegs ordentliche Grafikkarte hast.
Oh man.
Was hast du für ein PC? 8700K, 1080TE, 32G RAM, SSDs.
Also aus heutiger Sicht wirklich nichts besonderes mehr.
Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt an.
Kannst du dein Bewusstsein auf einen Computer speichern und ewig leben?
Auf geht's, kurz gesagt, erklär's uns.
Der Wunsch uns aus dem Gefängnis des physischen Körpers zu befreien ist so alt wie die ersten Legenden der Menschen.
Wir leben in diesem unendlichen Universum, dessen einzige Grenze die Physik ist.
Aber unser Bewusstsein ist in einer sterblichen Maschine...
Ich fühle mich, wenn ich die Stimme von dem Typ her...
Also es reicht mir schon, wenn ich den Sprecher höre, dass ich merke, dass mein IQ steigt.
...aus Fleisch gefangen.
Mit atemberaubend schnellem Fortschritt und immer neuen Innovationen scheint es aber plötzlich zum Greifen nah diesen Fleischberg zurück zu lassen.
Fleischberg, Fleischberg.
Na gut, sind wir mal ehrlich, bei den meisten stimmt's.
Wir müssen die digitale Utopie zu laden.
Vielleicht ist das sogar der nächste logische Evolutionsschritt.
Könnten wir unseren Geist wirklich in einen Computer laden und die digitale Unsterblichkeit erreichen?
Tja, ihr ahnt es schon, die Antwort ist kompliziert.
Ah.
Wer hätte das vermuten können?
Du bist wer? Danke für den Zap.
Ja.
Geist ist ja schwierig zu definieren.
Als Geist gelten sämtliche Fähigkeiten unseres Bewusstseins und der Intelligenz.
Also das, womit du dir...
Man müsste halt irgendwie das Gehirn simulieren können.
Einfach. Man müsste einfach nur das Gehirn simulieren.
Und dann es irgendwie schaffen, die Verbindung, die es jetzt quasi so alles in dem Gehirn gibt, in das Fake-Gehirn zu übertragen.
Nur. Easy.
Morgen. Start-up-Lounge.
Habt ihr schon mal das Video zu Chris Brill gesehen? Nein.
Was mich ja bei diesen Dingern immer ein bisschen...
Wie soll ich sagen? Was mir da immer ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen bereitet ist.
Stellt euch mal vor, ihr macht jetzt einen Snapshot von eurem Gehirn und speichert den in der Cloud.
Ihr sterbt ja nicht instant. Ihr lebt ja weiter.
Das heißt, euch gibt's dann zweimal.
Euch gibt's einmal real und einmal virtuell.
Ihr habt euch dann quasi...
In der Richtung wie geklont. Ihr habt euch gesnapshotted.
Hat jemand Upload geguckt auf Amazon? Die Serie?
Reicht, wenn man schon die erste Folge gesehen hat.
Da lösen die das ja relativ einfach.
Beim Upload in die Cloud wird ein Kopf weggesprengt.
Da hast du das Problem schon mal nicht.
Da gibt's ein Wort für...
Zweite Annahme. Irgendwann werden wir das Gehirn gut genug verstehen,
um mit der richtigen Technologie alle seine Eigenschaften gut genug nachzuahmen für eine digitale Kopie.
Es gibt ja Leute, die lassen sich jetzt schon einfrieren, weil sie denken, das wird dann irgendwann mal passieren.
Wobei ich halt glaube, selbst wenn wir das wirklich mal können sollten,
dass wir dann irgendwie tausend Jahre alte Gehirne einscannen können, halte ich dann trotzdem für sehr gewagt.
Und die Frage ist, wollen wir das überhaupt?
Also...
Dritte Annahme. Computersoftware kann den Geist ausführen.
Der Geist ist also berechenbar.
Jede physikalische Eigenschaft des Gehirns, auch das Bewusstsein, kann genau simuliert werden,
auch wenn es dazu eine ganze Menge Code braucht.
All diese Annahmen wurden...
Easy.
AI, Blockchain, Agile Scrum Master, Hirn simulieren.
... und Philosophen vorgebracht und auch wieder bestritten.
Und sie werden immer noch hitzig diskutiert, weil so viele grundlegende Fragen...
Eigentlich kein Problem. Perl One Liner.
... ist es ziemlich schwierig, dieses Thema zu besprechen, ohne jemanden vor den Kopf zu stoßen.
Aber egal, welchen Annahmen du Glauben schenkst, alle Diskussionen beginnen hier immer mit dem Gehirn.
Kurz gesagt, das Gehirn.
Das Gehirn ist die komplexeste uns bekannte biologische Struktur und hat ein ganzes Video verdient.
Also werfen wir hier nur einen kurzen Blick darauf.
Etwa 100 Milliarden Neuronen kommunizieren über eine Million Milliarden Verbindungen,
von denen jedes bis zu tausend Signale pro Sekunde...
Trivial.
Das ist eine Billarde Signale, jede einzelne Sekunde deines Lebens.
Es gibt aber nicht nur Neuronen, sondern auch Milliardenschutz...
iPad Simulator.
... verschiedene Art mit unterschiedlichen Aufgaben.
Grob kann das Gehirn in verschiedene Bereiche mit ihren eigenen Aufgaben unterteilt werden.
Etwa für die Atmung, den Herzschlag, die Bewegungskoordination oder unwillkürliche Reflexe.
Der am weitesten entwickelte Teil der Neokortex, also die äußerste Schicht des Gehirns,
speichert Erinnerungen und ermöglicht es uns außerdem,
Pläne zu schmieden, zu denken, zu hoffen, zu träumen und uns Dinge vorzustellen.
Wo im Hirn aber das Du liegt, wissen wir nicht genau.
Wir wissen, dass Regionen wie der Preconeus-Kortex den größten Einfluss auf unser Bewusstsein haben.
Aber auch das verschiedene...
Also mein EQ ist schon wieder...
Das geht durch die Decke gerade, wenn ich das Video gucke.
... Regionen zusammenarbeiten, um sich Arbeiten zu teilen, die sie alleine nicht schaffen.
Aber die verschiedenen Bausteine des Gehirns sind nicht gerade simpel.
Neuronen sind nicht einfach Kabel, sie verändern sich und verarbeiten Informationen.
Die Synapsen, über die die Signale von einem Neuron zum nächsten wandern,
enthalten Rezeptoren für hunderte chemische Signale,
weshalb sie anfällig sind für äußere Einflüsse.
Wir haben zwar ein grundlegendes Verständnis, wie das funktioniert
und können dem Kleinen auch voraussagen, wie sie sich verhalten,
aber das Gehirn ist weit mehr als nur ein paar Nervensignale.
Eine riesige Rolle spielen Hormone, etwa Serotonin, das unsere Laune beeinflusst,
oder Histamin, das uns besser lernen lässt.
Und auch andere Körperteile beeinflussen das Gehirn, etwa Herznerven oder Darmbakterien.
Was am Anfang schon kompliziert aussah, wird immer komplizierter...
Jaja, Darm ist wichtig.
... je näher wir uns damit befassen.
Um dieses extrem vernetzte Chaos aus Zellen, Fleisch und Biochemie
in einem Computer zu speichern, brauchen wir ein Modell,
das wir in der digitalen Umgebung simulieren können.
Eine Art Scan.
Unsere heutige Technologie für solche Scans, etwa FMRI-Maschinen,
sind dieser Aufgabe leider weitem nicht gewachsen.
Es gibt aber eine andere Methode, die ziemlich viel versprechen scheint.
Das Gehirn in hauchdünne Scheibchen schneiden.
... mit einem hochauflösenden Elektronenmikroskop scannen.
Das ist halt ein bisschen dumm, wenn du noch lebst.
... so eine genaue Karte aller Zellen und ihre Verbindungen erstellen können.
2019 gelang es Wissenschaftlern so, einen Kubik-Millimeter eines Mäusehirns abzubilden.
Also etwa die Größe eines Sandkornes.
Es bestand aus 100.000 Neuronen mit einer Milliarde Synapsen und 4 Kilometer Nervenfaser.
Dieses Körnchenhirn wurde in 25.000 Scheiben geschnitten.
5 Elektronenmikroskope arbeiteten ununterbrochen für 5 Monate...
Alter!
... und erstellten bis zu 100 Millionen Bilder.
Dann dauerte es 3 Monate, um aus diesen Bildern ein 3D-Modell zu erstellen.
Der fertige Datensatz braucht...
Und für die Größe von einem Sandkorn.
Nicht schlecht, ja.
... 1.000.000 Gigabyte Speicherplatz.
Das ganze menschliche Gehirn zu scannen würde eine Million Mal so viel Arbeit kosten.
Das ist sehr viel leichter gesagt als getan.
Noch schlimmer.
Für eine richtige Simulation bräuchten wir vielleicht noch viel kleinere Grundsteine,
um die Milliarden zugrunde liegenden Proteine oder sogar individuelle Moleküle zu erfassen,
die alles verhalten auf Zellebene steuern.
Für solch riesige Mengen Daten reicht vielleicht der gesamte Speicherplatz der Welt nicht aus.
Wie machen wir Hirnwasser zu Bewusstseinswein?
Was?
Das wäre eigentlich schon schwer genug.
Die wahre Frage ist aber, wie wir diesen statischen Bauplan des Gehirns in etwas Aktives verwandeln.
Selbst mit einem Scan bis zu den Synapsen brauchen wir Regeln und Gesetze, um diesen Bauplan zu aktivieren.
Nur so können wir der statischen Struktur Leben einhauchen
und sie mit den Gesetzen chemischer Bindungen und der Elektrodynamik füttern.
Erst damit wird die Simulation dynamisch wie das Gehirn,
welches von einer Mikrosekunde zur nächsten existiert und sich mit der Zeit weiterentwickelt,
das Denken, sehen und entscheiden kann.
Wir wissen aber nicht, ob das überhaupt klappt,
ob unsere Technologie jemals ein echtes Bewusstsein simulieren kann.
Alles hängt von einer grundlegenden Frage ab.
Sind Gehirn und Bewusstsein nur sehr kompliziert und schwierig zu verstehen
oder sind sie so komplex, dass wir sie niemals so ganz verstehen können?
Im schlimmsten Falle ist das Bewusstsein mehr als die Summe aller Hirnteile
und das ist uns einfach noch nicht klar.
So komplex, dass wir das auch mit besseren Scans nicht hinkriegen.
Vielleicht reicht es nicht, die Zutaten zu kennen, um ein richtiges Bewusstsein gebacken zu kriegen.
Wir haben eine gute Ausgangslage mit handfesten wissenschaftlichen Erkenntnissen und einem Ziel.
Der Weg zu einer echten Simulation ist aber sehr ungewiss
und verlangt eine Menge Innovation und Forschung.
Und historisch gesehen sind wir Menschen...
Oh, Peter. Peter disliked.
... nicht gerade gut darin, die Zukunft vorauszusagen.
Im besten Fall müssten wir einfach hart arbeiten und die richtigen Lösungen finden.
Vielleicht müssten wir gar nicht jede hinterletzte Zelle bis zum letzten Atom genau simulieren.
Vielleicht können wir stattdessen gewisse Elemente mit Wahrscheinlichkeitsmodellen vereinfachen,
die das Verhalten des Gehirns mit weniger und einfacheren Systemen abbilden könnten.
Wir wissen also nicht, ob wir Gehirn und Bewusstsein jemals gut genug begreifen werden,
um ein menschliches Bewusstsein zu digitalisieren.
Aber die Forschung dazu existiert und ist es wert, weiter verfolgt zu werden.
So oder so werden wir ziemlich viel über uns selbst erfahren
und dabei einige neue Technologien entwickeln.
Gelingt es, wird das Speichern unseres Bewusstseins vielleicht zu einem Teil unserer schnell fortschreitenden Computertechnologie.
Die Konsequenzen für die Menschheit und unsere Zukunft in diesem Universum
wären weitreichend ziemlich unheimlich und unfassbar.
Ja, wird noch eins, zwei Generationen dauern, genau.
Manchmal für mich wirkt das halt wie Megazukunftstechnologie, wenn überhaupt.
So was irgendwie, so was weiß ich in vielleicht in 500 Jahren oder sonst was.
Aber manche Sachen gehen schneller als man denkt und manche Sachen dauern viel länger als man glaubt.
Deswegen, da sinnvolle Predictions zu machen, ist glaube ich gar nicht möglich.
Ja, gut, bei den meisten Zuschauern auf YouTube und Twitch und Streamern auch nicht anders jetzt.
Das ist halt auch das, was ich mir so denke.
Was ist, wenn du wirklich, das ist das, was ich am Anfang gesagt habe, wenn du dich wirklich kopierst,
was passiert dann mit, weil du lebst ja weiter.
Das ist halt echt, ist ja komisch.
Oh ne, das will ich nicht.
Das will ich nicht.
Lass mich in Ruhe.
Ich will garantiert nicht mit mir selbst zusammenarbeiten.
Ich muss nicht.
Die Animationen sind echt gut von denen.
Was kommt als nächstes?
Der Cooper näht das Cluster für Gehirne.
Beides, du hattest keine genau die gleiche Idee gehabt.
Aber da kann man nichts essen, wenn man digital ist.
Ich meine, man kann Essen simulieren.
Man kann denken, man isst, obwohl man nichts isst.
Linux auf dem Desktop zum Beispiel könnte ich dann angehen.
Ne, mit Sicherheit nicht.
Na gut, das gibt es ja jetzt auch schon.
Ich könnte den ganzen Tag futtern, ohne dicker zu werden.
Das wird sich doch schon mal lohnen.
Übrigens war eines der Channels, wo ich finde, dass es lohnt,
von Gebühren zu bezahlen.
Wo wir gerade bei diesem Thema sind.
Habt ihr den Matrix 4 Trailer gesehen?
Ich muss euch sagen, mir ging es dann nicht so, als würde ich Matrix 4 gucken.
Mir ging es eher, als würde ich so einen Matrix John Wick Crossover gucken.
Er sieht halt einfach aus wie John Wick.
Er sieht halt nicht aus wie Neo.
Also irgendwie hat es mich ein bisschen kalt gelassen.
Dice-Response.
Es gibt eigentlich nur noch Outrage über alles.
Guckt auf Twitter.
Entweder sind die Leute übertrieben dafür oder übertrieben dagegen.
Leute, die Sachen realistisch versuchen einzuschätzen und sagen,
na ja, es liegt wahrscheinlich irgendwo in der Mitte, gibt es kaum.
Nur noch Outrage überall.
Wir wollen Go in 100 Sekunden.
Go in 100 Sekunden.
Übrigens sehr guter Channel.
Wer sich für Programmier- und Technik-Kram interessiert,
massiv guter Channel.
Fireship.
Das ist ein bisschen leise.
Zeig mich mal gleich nochmal.
Okay, ich hätte an anderen Sachen gedacht bei Go.
Ja, aber man muss nach Go Lang suchen, weil Go Google nicht ordentlich findet.
Ja, B war der Vorläufer von C.
Wie geht es dir? Alles gut?
Fuck, würde man sagen.
Ja, das ist auch so ein Ding.
Warum kannst du in Go so komische Dinge machen?
Du kannst in Go drei verschiedene Arten und Variablen zu deklarieren und installieren.
Aha, ja.
FMT printen.
Na ja, da kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Also ich finde, die Go-Syntax ist schon ziemlich weit weg von C.
Gar nicht eigentlich.
Aber keine Generics.
Easy, jetzt wirst du aber Bescheid.
Ich würde sagen, gleich mal GitHub Repo anlegen, erstes Go Projekt, easy.
Jetzt wirst du aber Bescheid.
Was empfiehlt uns denn heute YouTube?
Nix.
Was kann man denn konkret machen mit Go?
Kommt hauptsächlich aus dem Bereich Web?
Gibt es da überhaupt Use Cases?
Ja, im Frontend nicht, außer bei WebAssembly.
Aber sehr viele Backend-Services sind in Go programmiert.
Also ziemlich alles, was mit Clouds zu tun hat, ist in Go programmiert.
Also vieles davon ist in Go programmiert.
Sei es jetzt irgendwie von Terraform bis Kubernetes bis... ach, guck mal hier.
Top Go Projects GitHub.
Wir gucken einfach.
Muss ich doch gar nicht überlegen.
Trending Go Repositories, easy.
Also gucken wir uns mal an.
Eigentlich wollte ich Alltime, aber egal.
Docker, ganz Docker-Stalls.
Konsul.
Go selbst ist in Go.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Synthing.
Edgard Home, wo es schwer ist, dass es in Go ist.
Gibt es da irgendwie auch so eine Übersicht über insgesamt?
Ziemlich viel ist in Go.
Oh, ich bin immer noch müde.
Wie geht dann sowas?
Also YouTube empfiehlt uns nichts Gescheites.
Der verbotene Noctua-Lüfter-Swap.
Oh, Hetzener Werbung, excellent.
Ausrufezeichen Hetzener im Chat, wenn ihr euch 20 Euro Startguthaben für eure Cloud-Server
sichern wollt.
Wo ich gerade die Hetzener Werbung gesehen habe.
Der verbotene Noctua-Lüfter-Swap.
Und Span.
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen Video.
Hallo, der Aua.
Ich habe die Asus Noctua Edition 3070 angeschaut.
Da gab es ein bisschen Verwirrung auch von meiner Seite, was das Kühlerdesign angeht.
Beziehungsweise ich konnte eben durch einen direkten Bildervergleich, durch ein Bild,
das ich online von der 3070 Taffy Gaming gefunden habe.
Scenerics kommen Ende des Jahres, ja.
So wie die letzten zwei Jahre auch schon.
Bin mal gespannt, wann da wirklich was kommt.
Haben Sie diesmal jetzt in irgendeiner Preview-Version schon drinne?
Der 3070 Noctua Edition.
Erstmal auf den ersten Blick, wie ich gesagt habe, eben keinen Unterschied feststellen.
Ein fetter Passivkühler.
Also gut, da oben kommt dann auch Lüfter.
Aber was, ein fetter Kühlerblock, Mensch.
Bald gibt es Grafikkarten, die über vier Slots gehen.
Drei Slots gibt es ja schon.
Und ich habe ja gesagt zu Noctua, dass Sie sonst nicht bei mir melden.
An dieser Stelle viele Grüße an euch und danke, dass ihr euch gemeldet habt.
Denn es gibt tatsächlich Unterschiede, die schauen wir uns gleich an.
Ich habe auch mittlerweile eine 3070 Dual bekommen.
Die hatte ich mir eigentlich schon vor dem Video bestellt und dachte, die kommt dann auch an.
Ich dachte auch, dass die 3070 Dual eigentlich vom Grundprinzip her sehr ähnlich zu Tough Gaming und zu dieser 3070 Noctua Edition ist.
Musste dann aber auch feststellen, dass wenn man eben da auch die Bilder vergleicht, dass man sehr schnell den Drucklust bekommt, dass die ähnlich wären.
Die Platine ist glaube ich gleich, aber der Kühler ist auch da nochmal unterschiedlich.
Das Schöne ist, wir können dadurch, dass wir jetzt die Karte haben, auch nochmal einen Direktvergleich ziehen, was wäre.
Ich mag Noctua wirklich.
Ich habe auch relativ viele Noctua Lüfter und ich habe mir damals sogar eine Noctua Lüfter Mod gekauft mit Seitenteilen und Farben, die man auch so richtig bescheuert.
Dabei gucke ich in meinen Rechner nicht mal rein.
Ich habe zwar ein Gehäuse mit Seitenfenster, aber ich habe einen anderen Rechner davor stehen und ich kann da gar nicht reingucken.
Zumindest eine Sache, die mich bei Noctua immer noch ein bisschen gringen lässt, ist die Farbe.
Wobei, die können die Farbe nicht mehr ändern.
Die Farbe und dieses gesamte Konzept, diese Creme Farbe mit den braunen Ecken, das ist einfach komplett Markenzeichen von Noctua.
Wenn man jetzt den Dual Kühler gegen den Noctua Kühler tauscht, das können wir auf jeden Fall machen.
Ich weiß, es gibt Schwarze. Es gibt auch Mods, die man auf die Lüfter machen kann und dann sehen die schwarz aus.
Vielleicht der Noctua Kühler gegenüber zum Beispiel dem 3070 Dual Kühler.
Und viele von euch haben gesagt, ey, es ist ja voll praktisch, dass das hier ein normales Lüfter-Shroud ist.
Also dass wir hier quasi normale 120mm Lüfter verbaut haben.
Da habt ihr auch recht, es sind übrigens ganz normale 4P Lüfter.
Was ist denn das da? Ist das ein Kleber oder was ist das? Wärmeleitpads oder was genau ist da oben drauf in der Mitte?
Und viele von euch haben gesagt, okay, wie wäre es eigentlich, wenn man da schwarze Lüfter verbaut?
Ich habe mir schwarze Chroma-Lüfter gesagt. Die tauschen wir auch mal und vergleichen dann mal,
was sich da performenstechnisch gegenüber den A21 tut.
Das heutige Video wird unterstützt von Hetzner mit dem Dedicated Root Server AX41.
Bei mir nicht. Bei mir ist es Hetzner Cloud.
Also wenn ihr euch 20 Euro Startguthaben sichern wollt für die Hetzner Cloud, Ausrufezeichen Hetzner im Chat,
und sich dann mit meinem Code anmelden, lasst es trotzdem überlaufen.
... und legt dabei großen Wert auf die aktuellsten technischen Standards und gleichzeitig auch den Fokus auf die Umwelt,
wie zum Beispiel durch Verwenden von 100% Ökostrom.
In Finnland.
Das AX41 ist das Einstiegsmodell der Dedicated Root Server und ist standardmäßig mit dem Ryzen 5 3600 6-GaN Prozessor,
64 GB RAM und 2 512 GB NVME SSDs ausgestattet.
Das komplette Rackdesign und speziell auch die Kühlung sind komplett von Hetzner...
Ich würde sagen, mein Sellout ist persönlicher, oder?
... und bieten neben 24-7-Support eine schnelle Internetanbindung, DDoS-Schutz und...
Ist das wirklich dein Gebäude? Ja.
Du kannst mal bei denen auf der Homepage gucken, die haben sogar einen virtuellen Rechenzentrum-Rundgang.
Das ist wirklich der in ihr Gebäude.
Wir vergleichen jetzt erst mal kurz den Noctua-Kühler versus den 3070 TUF Gaming-Kühler.
Und wenn man jetzt einfach mal diese Bilder vergleicht, also oben haben wir den TUF Gaming-Kühler, unten haben wir den Noctua-Kühler.
Wenn man das einfach mal von oben im ersten Blick vergleicht, zieht es nicht wesentlich unterschiedlich aus.
Ich sehe da gar nichts.
Das Problem ist, dass man auf Bildern online logischerweise auch keinen Maßstab hat und es dann so einfach vergleichen kann.
Ich erkenne da gar keinen Unterschied, außer dass das eine ein bisschen länger ist.
Wir sehen aber, dass die Heatpipes tatsächlich etwas anders platziert sind und der Kühler auch höher ist.
Das war auch natürlich ein Problem, da ich keinen Shot von der Seite hatte von dem Kühler, sondern nur von oben.
Und die Höhe kann man da relativ schwierig erkennen.
Wenn wir oben schauen beim TUF Gaming-Kühler, da sehen wir das ca. 33 mm hoch.
Und wenn wir rechts unten schauen beim Noctua-Kühler, der ist 33 mm hoch.
Also einfach noch einen Slot oben drüber.
Komm, 5 HE Grafikkarte, kein Problem.
Das ist schon verglichen auf die Gesamthöhe ein ordentlicher Zuwachs an Kühloberfläche.
Dementsprechend ergibt sich alleine dadurch, wenn man selbst an den Heatpipes nichts ändert, schon mal ein guter Vorteil was die Kühlleistung betrifft.
Und wenn wir dann die Heatpipes vergleichen, da muss man dann einfach darauf vertrauen, dass Noctua dann einen guten Job gemacht hat
und sich auch was dabei gedacht hat, als sie dann die Heatpipes verschoben haben.
Und da sieht man, oben beim Kühler haben wir einen Heatpipe-Abstand von 22 mm.
Und beim unteren haben wir 25,7 mm.
Also da hat sich tatsächlich was verschoben, auch wenn es nur 3 mm sind, wird man schon aus einem guten Grund gemacht haben,
um die Wärme wahrscheinlich dann besser zu verteilen.
Aber das sind jetzt tatsächlich die Unterschiede zwischen der Noctua Edition und dem normalen Tablet.
Und warum genau sollte man das jetzt machen?
Das habe ich nicht verstanden, also warum sollte ich meine Lüfter austauschen?
Für Übertaktungsstellen wahrscheinlich.
Während die 3070 Dual sich jetzt gerade aufheizt im Test.
Weil klar kannst du sagen, Temperatur, Geräuschkulisse und sonst was, aber das ist ja auch bestimmt nicht billig.
So ein Noctua Lüfter Set mit dem passenden Rahmen dazu.
Ob sich das irgendwie lohnt, da habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Gut, aber ich habe mir auch Modding für meine Lüfter gekauft, die ich heute nicht sehe.
Also Preis ist nicht immer so der ausschlaggebende Faktor.
Nee, das ist wirklich irgendein Wärmelightpad.
Ich glaube, das ist kein Temperatursensor da oben drauf.
Das Fan schaut an von dem Noctua Kühler, denn hier ist auf der linken Seite Ihnen drin.
Das hatte ich im Video nicht so detailliert gezeigt.
Hier ist quasi einfach nur ein Lüfteradapter.
Da haben wir die zwei 4-Pin-Anschlüsse von den Lüftern.
Das war nämlich auch so ein bisschen Verwirrung bei manchen.
Zumindest in den Kommentaren hatte ich das gesehen.
Das sind wirklich die ganz normalen Lüfter.
Also da wurde nichts modifiziert.
Das sind immer noch die ganz normalen Lüfter.
Oder einfach noch Klebeband.
Dementsprechend ist es auch kein Problem, dass wir diese Lüfter einfach ausbauen
und andere Lüfter hieran anschließen.
Okay, jetzt circa 15 Minuten später.
Die Karte taktet minimal höher als...
Hat er das jetzt ausgetauscht?
Das liegt aber auch daran, weil die Noctua...
Okay, ich blicke diesmal nicht durch.
...von nicht im P-Profil, aber das sind 30 MHz.
Das kann man schon fast vernachlässigen.
Das könnte auch eine Sampleschwankung sein.
Wir sehen aber Fan-Speed ziemlich genau doppelt so hoch.
1900, fast 2000 Umdrehungen bei beiden Lüftern.
Wir sehen auch, die Leistungsaufnahme ist...
Zu ganz checken tue ich es nicht.
Um was geht es?
...zirka 4-5 Grad höher.
Also schon ganz alleine.
Subjektiv ist diese Karte deutlich, deutlich lauter.
Ah, normale Impulse Noctua, oder was?
...zirka 13 dBA mehr.
Hier haben wir jetzt die Chroma-Lüfter.
Oh, das ist viel.
13 dB, dB ist ja so eine total bescheuerte Skala,
die dann so locker rhythmisch rauf geht.
20 mm, die werden wir jetzt tauschen gegen die AF12.
Wobei man aber auch dazu sagen muss,
das Lüfter-Shroud hier ist ja generell auch so ein bisschen bräunlich gehalten,
damit es eben dem Design matcht.
Wie gesagt, ich finde es eigentlich so ziemlich geil, wie man das sieht,
weil ich auch das Lüftendesign von den Lüftern einfach mega, mega schön finde.
Wir tauschen das jetzt trotzdem mal und schauen uns an,
wie das aussehen würde, wenn man es einfach gegen schwarze Lüfter tauscht.
Aber auch Noctua-Lüfter.
Das können wir uns übrigens sparen an den Lüftern,
weil die Lüfter weder auf dem Kühler direkt aufliegen, noch hier.
Also auch hier auf der anderen Seite liegen die Lüfter direkt da auf.
Das hat man auch hier irgendwo gesehen, wenn man das so mal anschaut.
Also das wird da quasi eingequetscht.
Deswegen, ich dachte erst, wir bauen das drauf für besseres Entkoppeln,
aber wir brauchen das nicht.
Nicht mal 5 Minuten später, Lüfter sind drin.
Das Einzige, was nicht hundertprozentig passt, ist das Kabel hier.
Das müsste eigentlich so, keine Ahnung, 3, 4, 5 Millimeter länger sein,
dass man das hier durch die Kerbe durchlegen könnte,
dann hinten drauf stecken.
Ansonsten, bei dem Rechenlüfter, das Verlängerungskabel.
Okay, ich check das Video heute nicht, aber ich glaube, das liegt daran,
weil es davor noch ein anderes Video gab, was ich nicht geguckt habe.
Was kommt denn am Ende raus?
Wirklich gar nicht.
Okay.
Der Unterschied, ca. 1 dB.
Das ist schön leise, oder?
Und das ist bei der Genauigkeit, die ich hier habe, definitiv.
Schön leise.
Es ist sehr ähnlich.
Also Noctua kann das wirklich, dafür ist der Kram halt teuer.
Noctua lässt sich das gut bezahlen.
Was ich am Anfang bei Noctua immer richtig cool fand,
dass du bei Noctua immer alle möglichen Teile dabei hast.
Wenn du Noctua-Lüfter bestellst, du bekommst den Lüfter,
du bekommst diese, die ihr auch gerade gezeigt habt, diese Gummie-Ecken,
dann bekommst du diese Entkopplungspimmel, keine Ahnung, wie man die nennt.
Und du bekommst noch einen Adapter für Verlängerung,
du bekommst noch einen Adapter für Silent.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man halt sagen,
ich brauche nicht 15 Silent-Adapter nach einer Zeit.
Also es wäre cool, würden die das anbieten, ohne den ganzen Shit.
Und dann ein bisschen billiger.
Zu den A12-Lüftern, wir haben hier ca. 20 bis 30 Umdrehungen mehr.
Das macht wahrscheinlich keinen Unterschied.
RGB, jawoll, so muss es sein.
Das könnten im Prinzip auch die F12-Lüfter sein.
Ok, das ist mir zu high IQ heute.
Also ich habe ja bei mir schon seit 3 Jahren Noctua 12, ne, NHD 15, weiß ich gar nicht, ob das...
Ich glaube, den habe ich bei mir drauf, Moment.
Ich sage euch gleich, welchen ich drauf habe, Noctua.
Ah, hier.
NHD 15S, das ist der mit nur einem Lüfter, der mit nur einem Lüfter drauf.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin wirklich mega zufrieden.
Also das ist der beste CPU-Kühler, den ich mir vorstellen kann.
Ich würde sogar sagen, der beste CPU-Lüfter, den ich jahre.
Also wenn man einen Staubfilter im Gehäuse hat,
ansonsten ist natürlich alles ein bisschen dreckig mit der Zeit.
Das ist wunderbar, das Ding ist leise,
das Ding kühlt erst, fuck, ich kann meinen 8700K übertakten,
wenn ich das will, überhaupt keine Probleme.
Es ist einfach top.
Ich kann mich wirklich nicht beschweren.
Ich glaube, viel besseren CPU-Lüfter für meinen CPU kann man sich nicht kaufen.
Ja, und wenn es einem immer noch nicht reicht,
man kann natürlich noch einen zweiten Lüfter dran machen.
Was kostet denn der Kram mittlerweile?
Okay, Nocturne ist halt teuer.
76 oder 100 Euro, je nachdem in welcher Farbe,
für einen CPU-Kühler noch mal obendrauf.
Das ist halt schon eine Hausnummer.
Das ist schon eine Hausnummer.
Oder noch mehr.
Leider sieht der hässlich aus.
Naja, der sieht auch nicht bedeutend hässlicher aus
oder irgendwie besser aus als andere CPUs.
CPU-Tower-Kühler sehen noch alles so oder so ähnlich aus.
Das ist schon eine Hausnummer.
Ja, ich habe mir sowas hier gekauft, richtig hängen geblieben.
Ich glaube aber in schwarz oder in weiß.
Ich weiß nicht.
So ein Aufsatz für den...
Richtig dämlich.
So ein Aufsatz für den Dings.
Weil ich mir gedacht habe, das sieht total hängen geblieben.
Weiß nicht, warum ich das gekauft habe.
Vor allem, ich gucke noch nicht mal ins Gehäuse rein.
Einfach nur, einfach nur,
weil ich mir gedacht habe, das sieht total hängen geblieben.
Weiß nicht, warum ich das gekauft habe.
Einfach nur, einfach nur, weil es ging.
Ich glaube, weil Amazon mir das damals empfohlen hat.
Man weiß es nicht.
Ist ja wie der Apple-Shunt für 1000 Euro ja schon ein bisschen.
So, wir kommen uns eine Runde Lockpicking-Lawyer an.
Das muss sein.
This is the Lockpicking-Lawyer and what I have for you today
is another bike lock I will never understand.
But before I start, I want to answer what I'm sure...
Supreme.
Also man kann sich ja eins merken.
Umso mehr Premium und sonst was drauf steht, umso schlechter ist es.
Am besten sieht man das an Katzenfutter.
Dort, wo möglichst viel Premium, Deluxe, Gold, Gourmet drauf steht,
umso beschissener sind die Zutaten.
Top comment.
This bandage was the result of my carelessness with the most dangerous of kitchen utensils,
the mandolin slicer.
That said, the potatoes and the gratin I made were definitely worth the price.
Ist das Toss? Man darf keine Selbstverletzungen auf Twitch zeigen.
Now what's definitely not worth the price is this.
It's a Supreme branded Kryptonite Evolution Mini Bike Lock.
It was sent to me by Margo in Athens, Georgia,
soon after I featured a similar product in video number 1320.
Jetzt wenn ich Georgia hör.
Es gab ja mal so einen richtigen, richtigen Maus Kokona Post aller Zeiten.
Könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern, als die Russen in Georgien waren mit Panzern?
Und da hat irgendein Ami auf Yahoo Questions, als es das noch gab, gepostet.
Der hat in Georgia gelebt und da hat gesagt, er hat Angst aus dem Haus zu gehen.
Er hat in den Nachrichten gehört, die Russen sind mit Panzern da.
Da hab ich mir auch gedacht, alter, ist es fake? Ist es kein Fake?
Wahrscheinlich ist es kein Fake. Wahrscheinlich ist es kein Fake.
Die blinken das wirklich nicht.
Also mehr Kokona Post geht nicht.
Was? Wo ist denn hier ein Designer Logo drauf?
Ach, Supreme. Ach, das ist, Supreme ist die Marke oder was?
Ich dachte Supreme ist, das ist quasi ein Supreme Schloss.
Okay, wir wissen jetzt schon, was passiert.
Er wackelt da dreimal mit seinen krassen Skills daran rum und das ist auf.
Okay, ich habe das in Position.
Jetzt finden wir Disk Nummer 2 und gehen zum Picken.
Okay, ein schönes Klicken aus 2.
Was binden?
Klicken auf 3.
Ich habe von 4 ausgeliefert.
Da sind wir, wir haben nur 4 gesetzt.
Nummer 5, ein schönes Klicken dort.
6 ist ausgeliefert, fühlt sich wie ein 0.
Und das ist der letzte Disk.
Okay, probieren wir, auf Nummer 6 zu tensionieren und Disk Nummer 1 zu setzten.
Und wir haben das geöffnet.
Easy!
Okay, Leute, wie gesagt, es ist ziemlich ausgeliefert in Pick Resistenz und es hat nicht so lange gedauert, um mich zu öffnen.
Er hat es einfach drauf.
Was?
Der Supreme Hype ist komplett an Max vorbeigegangen.
Ja, ich kenne das gar nicht.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Nein, wirklich nie.
Ich wusste nicht, dass das ein Ding ist.
Habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ich habe letztens gelernt, dass Gucci-Caps voll angesagt sind.
Das war es aber auch.
Die haben T-Shirts für ein paar hundert Euro verkauft.
Na, für 300 Euro kann ich mal eine Gucci-Cap kaufen.
Oh, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch so?
Ah, Far Cry 6 ist ja raus.
Das müssen wir uns jetzt angucken.
Ich will wissen, ob das taugt.
Chat, was sagt ihr?
Hat das jemand von euch schon gespielt?
Sagt ihr, das taugt?
Google mal Supreme Ziegelstein.
Ernsthaft?
Das ist doch fake, oder?
Das ist doch fake.
Warum?
Warum gibt es da von Ziegelsteine?
Was ein Schwachsinn, Alter.
So, Half-Life, äh, nicht Half-Life 6, Far Cry 6.
Half-Life 6 wäre auch was.
Da wäre nämlich Half-Life 3, 4 und 5 schon raus.
Far Cry 6 wird genau das gleiche wie Far Cry 3 bis 5.
Hä, ich muss sagen, Far Cry oder Primal darf man nicht vergessen.
Far Cry 3 fand ich nice, 4 auch.
Primal hat mich nicht gejuckt.
5er fand ich auch nicht ansprechend.
Und den 5er Teil 2 auch nicht.
Gucken, vielleicht wird das wieder ein Gutes.
Lies bitte mal den Kommentar.
Okay, also, was soll ich lesen?
P, N, Y, Quattro...
Den Comment, okay.
Da komme ich jetzt irgendwo Rickrollen raus.
Das ist teuer.
Ja, Quattro-Karten sind teuer.
Perfekte Karte, aber...
Ja, gut.
Das ist halt, das ist halt fake.
Das ist halt debated.
Das ist halt, der hat es dir gar nicht gekauft.
Far Cry Primal hat dich abgestoßen, nachdem Katja K. dafür Werbung gemacht hat.
Ist das schlimm, wenn man nicht mal weiß, wer Katja K. überhaupt ist?
Wer ist, wer, wer ist Katja K.?
Ach, ist das, ist das Katja K., äh, Dings, Krasser...
Ach, die!
Ja, ja, ja, ja, jetzt weiß ich wieder.
Die nicht mehr so aussieht wie vorher, weil die sich irgendwie mit irgendwelchen, äh, Schönheits-OPs hat zuspritzen lassen.
Jaja, okay, jetzt weiß ich, jetzt weiß ich, wen du meinst, alles klar.
Jaja.
Gibt's die eigentlich noch? Katja K. YouTube.
Gibt's die noch?
Fuck.
Die gibt's nicht mehr, oder?
Die, die macht jetzt...
Die macht Musik, das kann ich nicht anklicken.
Erstens Toss, und außerdem will ich das gar nicht hören.
Die ist jetzt Rapperin, ja, das passt zu der.
Das, das, das passt zu der.
Da, das, äh, da hat sich gesucht und gefunden.
Äh, ich hör das nicht, ich hör mir das nirgendswo an.
Das ist, also, da müsste ich ja Geld dafür bekommen, dass ich mir das anhör.
Okay, also Far Cry 6, wie ist Far Cry 6, muss ich mir das angucken, ob es sich lohnt zu kaufen.
Aha.
Ist das, hat das irgendein Squad-System, oder was ist das da oben drüber?
Oder ist das einfach, dass der Gegner verwundet ist?
Ich kenne noch was, was für jede gute Idee eine schlechte hat.
Weiß ich, schon was von Windows 11 gehört.
Die haben ja auch gute Ideen, aber viel Schlechtes.
Was ich mich frage ist, ob die was aus der Story gemacht haben.
Mein, das sah ja im Trailer recht interessant aus, ob die da irgendwas auf die Reihe gekriegt haben.
Warum sehen die Rebellen alle schon so Hipster-mäßig aus?
Ich dachte immer gerade Rebellen in solchen Ländern, die sie müssen, die haben andere Probleme.
Warum weiß man nicht.
Was ein Dialog, was ein Dialog.
Pass auf, was ein Dialog, Alter.
Was ein scheiß Dialog, ist das schlecht.
Ich könnte jederzeit gehen, ich bleibe aber inspirierend.
Gut, das ist ja nichts Neues, das ist ja in jedem Far Cry so.
Außer in Far Cry 1, was mit den aktuellen Far Crys ja nichts zu tun hat.
Geht's nicht.
Sag mal, warum halten die Gegner so viel aus?
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, die Far Cry 3, wenn du da was Headshotted hast, war vorbei.
Und die haben die Gegner jetzt level oder sowas?
Leveln die Gegner?
Please nicht leveln die Gegner.
Da habe ich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Muss das echt sein?
Ja, es gab Juggernaut-Gegner in Far Cry 3, aber es gab keine verschiedenen Leveln in den Gegner.
Hast du den Far Cry Film mit Hilt Schweiger gesehen?
Nein, nein, ich will dich auch nicht.
Die Grundlegende Terrier-Handlung ist sehr ernst und wird auch in all ihrer Brutalität immer wieder gezeigt.
In jedem der drei Gebiete treffen wir auf eine neue Gruppe, der wir helfen müssen.
Dabei erleben wir kleine in sich nahezu abgeschlossene Handlungsthemen.
Ja, diese Geschichte mit, das hatten sie ja in Far Cry 4 schon.
Oberbösewicht hat vier Generäle, die du nach und nach killen musst und dann musst du dann in die Villa stürmen im vierten Teil am Schluss.
Aber ich muss sagen, die Map ist richtig groß.
Ja, das kriegen die bei Ubisoft immer gut hin, große Maps.
Guck dir das letzte Assassin's Creed an, aber halt wenig Substanz.
Mal gucken, wie das hier ist.
... ähnlich wie in Assassin's Creed Valhalla.
Bei den Monteros in Madrugada funktioniert das auch sehr, sehr gut.
Wir lernen die mörderische Tochter der Familie kennen, erfahren von der Verbitterung des Vaters und später auch noch ein paar Geheimnisse über den Sohn.
Der Tüftler Philly sorgt mit dem süßen Chorizo hingegen für eine schöne Prise Verrücktheit, die aber nicht fehl am Platz wirkt.
Gewurscht.
Alter, was sind das für ultra hipster Rebellen schon wieder?
Was ist denn das?
Haben die nichts besseres zu tun, wenn sie irgendwelche undergroundere Rebellen sind?
Oh, cringe, Alter!
Oh, was haben die sich denn da wieder beigedacht?
Heinz-Champ, Mann!
Sieht aus wie ein Drogensüchtiger aus Frankfurt, naja, nicht wirklich, aber gewisse Parallelen sind schon zu erkennen.
Ja, da habe ich jetzt eigentlich gedacht, da kriegen sie was hin, weil ich fand den ersten Trailer mit ihm und da wo er mit seinem Sohn und auf dem Dach und so, das sah eigentlich vielversprechend aus.
Was eigentlich ziemlich bescheuert ist, weil wenn der Typ seine Bevölkerung halt umbringt, dann ist er halt auch demnächst weg vom Fenster, weil dann ist keiner mehr da.
Das ist sowas, was in echt auch oftmals nicht so richtig funktioniert.
Also in Spielen haben sie das immer gerne.
Die böse Wichte sind halt ultra böse und bashen alles, aber selbst wenn du mal nach Afrika guckst, wo ja nur wirklich mono-Totschlag in manchen Gebieten einer Tagesordnung ist, selbst da brauchen die Leute, die auf irgendwelchen Plantagen arbeiten oder halt generell Arbeitskraft zur Verfügung stellen.
Du kannst nicht einfach random rumfahren und einfach 80% der Bevölkerung umbringen und denken, du bist noch da danach. Du bist vielleicht noch da danach, aber nicht mehr lange.
Und das ist in Spielen teilweise ein bisschen übertrieben.
Oh Peter!
Peter disliked wieder.
Na wie willst du denn Hanenkampf richtig oder gar nicht einbauen?
Wie soll ich mir das vorstellen?
Das ist doch eingebaut.
Oder hätte man sagen sollen, dass das schlecht ist?
Ich meine, auf der anderen Seite rennst du da rum und ballerst 30.000 Gegner über den Haufen, das ist auch schlecht.
Letztendlich ist es immer noch ein Game.
Im Endeffekt ist es immer noch ein Game.
Cockfight, ja, stimmt.
Eine Mission, wo man die befreit, das könnte man zum Beispiel einbauen, ja, das finde ich keine schlechte Idee.
Alter, was ist mit den Gegnern? Okay, das ist so ein Juggernaut-Gegner.
Ich glaube, die Gegner leveln doch nicht.
Weil levelnde Gegner geht mir immer auf den Sack.
Also das hat, mir persönlich hat in Far Cry 3 am meisten Bock gemacht, wenn man so ein Zwischending gemacht hat.
Also man ist quasi reingeschlichen von der Seite.
Aim, na das ist wahrscheinlich Controller-Aim von jemand, der es nicht controller spielt normalerweise.
In Far Cry 3 fand ich es am besten, du bist dann quasi von der Seite so ein bisschen reingestellt,
hast dann irgendwie drei, vier Gegner mit irgendwelchen coolen Moves nahkampfmäßig ausgeschaltet,
den Rest dann halt weggeballert mit dem Bogen.
Oder du bist komplett gestellt mit dem Bogen.
Das fand ich halt wirklich in Far Cry 3 cool.
Du konntest ein Lager so machen, ein anderes Lager komplett anders und das dritte Lager wieder komplett anders.
Fand ich wirklich nice.
Far Cry 3 müsste ich auch mal wieder spielen.
Sag mal, ich wollte grad sagen, warum checken die das nicht?
Stimmt, warum haben die Lebensbalken, warum haben die Lebensbalken die Gegner?
Die leveln doch, die leveln doch.
...bringen nur wie viele Treffer wir und die Gegenüber aushalten. Die Soldaten bleiben aber immer gleich anspruchslos, das fühlt sich unbefriedigend an, ist aber für Far Cry Fans auch nichts Neues.
Ja, die Gegner, die leveln.
Dafür haben die Hauptmissionen eine Menge Spaß, weil sie schön abwechslungsreich ausfallen.
Mal müssen wir in eine Plantage einfallen, nur um zu merken, dass hier irgendwie keiner mehr lebt
und dann fliehen wir nach einer kleinen Sequenz auch noch aus diesem Anwesen hier.
Dann vernichten wir überall verstreute Drogenbehälter oder erledigen einen Feind in einem wascheckten Bosskampf.
Ein Bosskampf Heli vs. RPG, das hat es ja noch nie gegeben.
Groundbreaking.
Die leveln nicht, sie haben statisches Level. Ja, ich meine, dass die Gegner überhaupt ein Level haben, ist doof.
Kurzum, hier wird einiges geboten und das wird auch so schnell nicht langweilig, weil sich die Waffen durch Sounddesign und Trefferfeedback bei den Feinden allesamt gut anfühlen.
Reckt.
Allesamt, naja, seit Teil 5 hat sich insgesamt dennoch zu wenig verbessert.
Geräusche und Reaktionen sind ein bisschen besser, aber auch nur mit den passenden Waffen.
Pfeile sorgen für ein gutes Feedback.
Zack.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Nee, das ist ja Bullet Sponges.
Warum ist der, sag mal.
Jetzt mal ernsthaft. Meint er, wenn der Panzer beschossen wird, denkt er sich nix bei und fährt einfach weiter.
High IQ Gegner.
Guckt euch das mal an, Massive High IQ Gegner.
Ah ja, ich krieg nen RPG, ich krieg nen RPG auf den Kopf. Ach interessiert mich, ich fahr einfach im gleichen Tempo weiter.
Warum sehen die alle so hip aus? Das sind irgendwelche Rebellen.
Das sind keine reichen Hipster Leute, das sind irgendwelche Rebellen. Warum sehen die alle so gestylen aus?
Oh, da haben sie sich aber Mühe gegeben.
Wahrscheinlich ist in den Hund mehr Entwicklungszeit reingeflossen als in die meisten Missionen und in die Story.
Ja, das sieht nicht so aus, als ist da Krieg oder so. Die sehen aus, als kommen die von der letzten, äh, wie heißt dieses Ding bei uns?
Ich hab vergessen, es gibt so nen Hipster Laden bei uns auf der Zeil, wo es so dunkel drin ist und wo die ganzen jungen Leute immer reinrennen.
Ähm, da ist, da ist dunkel drin. Wie heißt das, was war mal?
Mai-Zeil, äh, Mode, dunkel, keine Ahnung. Mai-Zeil.
Es gibt, Hollister, Hollister ist das, genau, ja. Weiß nicht, ob das noch angesagt ist.
Wenn du da vorbeiläufst, denkst, denkst du, das ist einfach das Licht ausgefallen?
Und, äh, in Wirklichkeit ist das Absicht, da ist dunkel. Ich war da noch nie drin, ich weiß nicht, warum man da rein will, aber keine Ahnung.
Denn zumindest sehen die eher aus, wie aus so nem Mai-Zeil-Klamottenladen, als von, äh, von der Rebellion.
Und davon gibt es wirklich ne ganze Menge. Also wirklich so viel, dass wir uns teilweise erschlagen gefühlt haben.
Wir können den fragwürdigen Hahnkampf bestreiten, Schad suchen und soviel, bei denen wir kleine Hinweise oder Kletterrätsel verfolgen.
Kisten suchen, in denen wir neue Waffen und Ressourcen finden.
Das kann Ubisoft ja gut. Das kann Ubisoft ja gut. Die Map mit Dingern zukleistern, die eigentlich niemand braucht.
In Far Cry 3 war das noch ein bisschen verhaltener. Du hattest diese Schad-Suche, du hattest ein paar Kill-Aufträge, du hattest irgendwie die Jagd-Aufträge.
Aber das hat, das ging. Das konntest du alles machen und es war alles auch ganz nice, du musstest nicht.
Aber es war nicht so mega zugekleistert.
Naja, man läuft wahrscheinlich rum, dass du irgendwelche Pre-Order-Items und Microtransactions an deinem Charakter siehst.
Ihr merkt schon, Far Cry 6 ist wirklich unglaublich vollgestopft mit Aktivitäten.
An der Wings-Suite sind wir noch genau das Gleiche, wie in 3 und 4.
Nur gibt es bei all den tollen Ideen und Möglichkeiten, wie eben kurz angreifen, ein ganz großes Problem.
Es gibt nach kurzer Zeit kaum noch Anreize, all das auch wirklich zu tun.
Ein Beispiel, wir stellen an Werkbänken spezielle Munition in unseren Waffen her.
Ich hoffe nächste Woche, also Dienstag, Mittwoch, ich werde das jetzt fertig machen.
Das wird auf jeden Fall das nächste Video, wenn nicht auch irgendwas anderes dann dazwischenkommt.
Man weiß ja nie.
Sonderseffektiv Panzerung durchschlägt. In der Praxis macht sich das aber einfach kaum bemerkbar.
Wir kommen relativ schnell mit so ziemlich jedem Schießeisen durch die Rüstung des Feindes hindurch.
Wieso also erst damit herum experimentieren? Noch vertaner, wir sammeln bereits...
Weil man sich gedacht hat, ich sage euch warum das so ist.
Weil man sich gedacht hat, das können wir ja dem 0815-2-Sekunden-Aufmerksamkeit-Spieler nicht zumuten.
Also bauen wir irgendwas ein, was eigentlich cool ist, aber dann stellen wir fest, fuck.
Der muss sich ja eine Viertelstunde mit dem Game beschäftigen, bis er es verstanden hat.
Und der muss auch ein bisschen experimentieren und danach denken. Das geht nicht.
Wir bauen einfach OP-Waffen ein, die man in der Story bekommt, dass man das Ganze nicht mehr braucht.
Deswegen haben sie es eingebaut.
Man muss heute leider diese Sachen auf den kleinsten gemeinsamen Dämlichkeits-Nenner versimpeln.
Ansätze davon sieht man übrigens auch in Battlefield 2042.
Legendäre Pistole ein, die wir nie wieder ausgetauscht haben, denn diese besonderen Waffen sind viel stärker als alle normalen Schießeisen und haben auch schon feste Bohnen.
Es ist seicht. Ich glaube auch nicht, dass es wirklich negativ wäre, wenn man denken müsste.
Oder zumindest, ich mag ja auch sinnlose Schalterrätsel oder so nicht, wo man keine Chance hat dahinter zu kommen.
Aber ich glaube, die haben einfach Schiss davor, dass die Leute sagen, ach nee, Drecks-Game, ich komme nicht weiter.
Ich meine, die Leute sind schon hardcore dämlich.
Ich erinnere mich beispielsweise noch an das letzte Pathfinder-Game.
Also nicht, dass nicht Wrath of the Right ist, also nicht das aktuelle, sondern Kingmaker, das davor.
Da gab es Leute, zum Release gab es reihenweise negative Reviews zu.
Mal gucken, wie das jetzt eigentlich aussieht.
Reihenweise negative Reviews, wobei ich immer noch der Meinung bin, dass das eines der besten Classic RPGs der letzten Jahre gewesen ist.
Und reihenweise negative Reviews, weil die Leute nicht den ersten Dungeon geschafft haben.
Warum haben sie nicht den ersten Dungeon geschafft?
Naja, in dem ersten Dungeon hat man, wie man im Low-Level-Bereich üblich, hat man irgendwelche Ratten und Insekten bekämpft.
Weil erster Dungeon in RPGs Level 1, die sind halt oftmals so.
Nur mit dem Unterschied, dass das Game, die gesagt hat, ey, nimm Bomben mit und nimm AE-Feuerzauber mit, damit du den Dungeon schaffen kannst.
Also die wollten ja quasi sagen, dass man viele Gegner am besten mit Area-Effekten bekämpft.
Eigentlich total logisch.
Und die Leute sind halt da rein, haben es nicht gecheckt, sind mit ihren melee Nahkampf-Charaktern in den Insekten-Schwarm gerannt und wurden gekillt.
Und haben dann gesagt, fucking Game, Design sucks, unbalanced, kann man nicht schaffen.
Dabei hätte man einfach mal das machen müssen, was da stand.
Flächende AE-Zauber, Feuerzauber, Bomben, irgendwas mitnehmen müssen.
Der erste Dungeon war nicht schwer, war easy.
Die Leute sind so dämlich, was das angeht, das ist unglaublich.
Und man muss ja sagen, man bekommt ja in den meisten Games heute schon relativ viel erklärt.
Also du hast meistens Tutorials in Form von, dieser Button macht das im Vergleich zu.
Ich meine, vergleich mal heute, vergleich mal, wir nehmen einen halbwegs aktuelles Classic RPG, nennen wir Dragon Age Origin.
Vergleichen wir das mal, und das ist auch schon 10 Jahre alt.
Vergleichen wir da mal den Einstieg mit dem ersten Baldur's Gate.
Im ersten Baldur's Gate hattest du von Anfang an keine Ahnung, was du eigentlich machst.
Du hast eine Character Creation, ohne dass du weißt, was eigentlich genau passiert.
Du hattest nichts.
Es war einfach, die haben dich einfach ins Game geschmissen.
Und du hast gedacht, okay, was will das Spiel von mir?
Ich glaube, da gab es ja sogar mal irgendeine Analyse zu.
Ich glaube die meisten, ich glaube irgendwie 70% der Spieler haben es nicht aufs Candlekeep gepackt.
In Baldur's Gate 1 bei Tests.
Das war einfach komplett lost.
Candlekeep ist quasi die Start des Tutorials von Baldur's Gate 1.
Ich glaube, 70% der Leute haben es nicht rausgeschafft.
So, und in Dragon Age, und das ist auch schon wieder 10 Jahre her, da war es noch nicht ganz so schlimm.
Da hast du eine richtige Tutorial Mission, wo du es erklärt kriegst.
Wo du in diese Wildnis musst und dann Morrigan triffst.
Da hast du ein richtiges Tutorial, du wusstest viel mehr, was abgeht.
Und mittlerweile ist es so, dass du nicht nur irgendein ultra nerviges Unskippable Tutorial kriegst.
Das Spiel denkt noch für dich mit.
Und sagt, ja nee, Moment, Entscheidungen und Nachdenken.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, das kriegen die Spieler nicht auf die Reihe.
Das müssen wir abkürzen.
Früher hat man sich die Infos aus Foren geholt, oder noch früher.
Man hat sich darüber unterhalten, so nach dem Motto, wusstest du schon.
Da müssten die Leute seit Souls nicht gut mit Clovers klarkommen.
Nein, Dark Souls ist ja nur so erfolgreich, weil es eben...
Dark Souls ist eine wirklich sehr gekonnte Mischung aus Atmosphäre, Design, Kampfsystem,
lernen und besser werden, was motiviert.
Aber Dark Souls ist jetzt sicherlich auch nicht das Game, wo du...
Ich meine, klar, Dark Souls war ultra erfolgreich, aber es war schon eine mega spezielle Mischung.
Es gibt genug Games, die versuchen, Dark Souls nachzumachen und es nicht schaffen.
Aber Dark Souls ist jetzt halt auch kein Game, wo du irgendwie jetzt 15 Millionen Spieler
oder so mit ansprichst.
Klar, das hat sich gut verkauft, hat riesen Fanbase.
Aber die meisten Leute sind...
Ich meine, du kannst einem Mobile-Spieler keinen Dark Souls in die Hand drücken.
Den meisten zumindest nicht.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Aber für diese Spieler sind mittlerweile die meisten Sachen halt designt.
Keine 5 Sekunden Aufmerksamkeitsspanne, keinerlei Nachdenken mehr wollen.
Und dann kommst du halt zu solchen Dingen an, dass man eigentlich eine coole Mechanik
im Game drinne hat, wie dieses Waffen craften und sammeln und wie auch immer das ist.
Aber man hat sich gesagt, fuck, das kann man den Leuten nicht zumuten.
Man baut einfach die Fallwaffen ein, mit denen du alles easy clearen kannst.
Womit man sein eigenes System eigentlich komplett in Frage stellt.
Nein, die Spiele sind nicht wirklich komplexer.
Die Spiele sind heutzutage vielleicht, was die Spielwelt, was Open-World-Sachen angeht,
komplexer und größer.
Aber mechanikmäßig würde ich nicht sagen, dass das wirklich komplexer ist.
Aber wir haben einfach zu schnell viel bessere Pistolen und Gewehre.
Wir brauchen eigentlich die ganzen Standardsachen nicht mehr.
Und das wiegt sich sogar auf das eigentlich schön offene Missionsdesign aus.
Wir können schleichen, ja, aber wir brauchen es schlicht irgendwann nicht mehr,
weil ballern bei gleichem Ergebnis deutlich schneller geht.
Die Gegner müssen leveln, sonst müssten die doch down sein von 1-2 Headshots.
Selbst die temporären Boni von den Bauten in den Rebellenlagern sind schnell überflüssig,
weil sie uns beispielsweise zwar für ein paar Minuten immun gegen Gift machen,
aber ein gefundenes Kleidungsstück macht das auch.
Und weil wir mitten im Gefecht ohne Probleme alle Waffen und Rüstungsteile austauschen können,
werden die Boni absolut überflüssig.
Traben wir einmal unser perfektes Arsenal zusammen, brauchen wir eigentlich nicht mehr
nach Waffensuchen, was fasst den gesamten Anreiz zum Erkunden der Open-World-Sachen.
Gleichzeitig ist die Insel aber optisch hübsch gestaltet und die Mission...
Hey, das muss man den Leuten bei Ubisoft lassen, also hübsche Landschaftssachen können die gut.
Das Dilemma, oder? Zumal Dani auch keinen Fertigkeitenbaum mehr hat.
Alles ist an Waffen und Kleidung gekoppelt, die wir aufrüsten können,
oder bei legendären Stücken eben auch nicht.
Zwar sparen wir uns dann das lästige...
Warum gibt es denn schon wieder unterschiedliche Loot-Stufen?
Jedes Ubisoft-Spiel ist mittlerweile so ein halbes RPG,
Aufwerten von Rüstungstaschen, aber es bleibt eben auch bei der mangelnden Belohnungsspirale.
Was schade ist, weil durch die verschiedenen Munitions- und Waffentypen
alles für ein motivierendes System da ist. Far Cry 6 stellt sich hier...
Das Schlimmste, das Schlimmste, was sie gemacht haben, ist Ghost Recon...
Wie hieß das letzte, Breakpoint oder so?
Da wo ich ein sehr laut Video zugemacht habe und mir wirklich schwer gefallen ist,
was Gutes zu zu sagen.
...Items und doofen Gegnern einfach nicht mehr zu machen.
...Items und doofen Gegnern einfach selbst ein Bein.
Selbst bei der Technik kommen einige Abas auf euch zu.
Far Cry 6 sieht fantastisch aus.
Allerdings konnte unser Technikexperte Alex Köpf keine großen Unterschiede
zwischen normalen und HD-Texturen erkennen.
Ihr solltet euch also gut überlegen, ob ihr sie wirklich installieren wollt,
weil sie mit 40GB noch einmal sehr viel Sprecher benötigen
und logischerweise etwas mehr Leistung fressen.
Vor allem, weil man dafür rund 11-12 Video-Ramen benötigt.
Ansonsten laden die Texturen nicht richtig und sorgen für verwaschene Oberflächen.
Mit Raytracing und 4K-Auflösung sind es im integrierten Benchmark bis zu 15,5 GB.
Im Spiel selbst messen wir 11-12.
Dafür lief der Shooter auf mehreren Systemen sehr flüssig.
Aber Raytracing benötigt ebenfalls viel Power und kann um die 20% Reformen kosten.
Ah, kann ich drauf verzichten.
Auf der anderen Seite konnten wir ohne spülbaren Verlust mit einer RX 6800 XT 4K anschalten
und das mit 70 Bildern pro Sekunde.
In die Kategorie Merkwürdig fällt die FPS-Rate in den Zwischensequenzen.
Die ist nämlich auf 30 Bilder pro Sekunde festgesetzt
und alle Cutscenes wirken dadurch deutlich unruhiger als der Rest des Spiels.
Besonders doof, weil ausgerechnet der toll gespielte Bösewicht Castillo
fast ausschließlich in diesen Sequenzen auftaucht.
Da hat man schon einen fantastischen Schauspieler wie Giancarlo Esposito
und lässt es ruckeln.
Tja, warum eigentlich?
Warum macht man eigentlich Zwischensequenzen mit 30 FPS
einfach um Speicher zu sparen, oder wie?
Ansonsten sehe ich da überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Z.B. das ist gerendert.
Das kannst du auch mit 240 rendern, wenn du willst.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Affig.
Wunderbar. Hey, Dani.
Dani!
In Summe bleibt Far Cry 6 damit ein sehr gutes Spiel,
bei dem wir rund 30 Stunden lang viel Spaß gehabt haben
und das war ja auch das große Ziel der Entwickler.
Wenn da nur nicht die ganzen Aber's wären.
Denn eigentlich steckt hier noch ein viel besseres Abenteuer drin,
dass ihr die selbst unglaublich im Weg steht
und durch die zusammengepflegte Stimmung,
die undurchdachten Gameplay-Systeme
starkwürdigen Darstellungen bestimmter Themen
deutlich schlechter ausfällt, als es sein müsste.
Und das sieht man eben an kaum einer Szene so gut wie die vom Anfang,
bei der wir immer noch dieselbe Pistole wie zum Start nutzen
und trotzdem keine bessere einsetzen müssen.
Es macht Spaß, aber es bleibt auch eben weit unter seinen Möglichkeiten.
Ja.
Weiß ich nicht. Vielleicht hol ich mir es trotzdem.
Ich hätte schon mal Bock wieder auf ein ordentliches Far Cry.
Und es scheint ja zumindest in der Kerndisziplin
ganz brauchbar zu sein.
So ein ordentliches...
Also ich würde gerne mal wieder Far Cry spielen.
Oder ich spiele einfach Far Cry 3 noch mal durch.
Wäre auch eine Möglichkeit.
Das macht Spaß schon.
Ob es noch irgendwas zu machen?
Wie lange bin ich schon schon on? 12 vor 15.
Ich hatte heute eigentlich vor, heute Abend noch mal zu streamen und...
Aber ich kann euch das nicht versprechen.
Eigentlich hatte ich vor,
dass ich heute Abend noch mal zu streamen und...
Aber ich kann euch das nicht versprechen.
Eigentlich hatte ich vor,
bisschen kürzer heute Morgen zu machen und Abend noch mal zu streamen,
denn wir müssen heute Abend die
China-Chinesen-Geräte endlich mal flashen.
Das Chines war ja da.
In Form von einem Hermesmann.
Der gar nicht so chinesisch aussah.
Und hat mir China-Geräte gebracht.
Gosun-Steckdosen.
Gibt es custom-Firmware. Kann man auch OTA flashen, glaube ich.
Habe ich hier schon mal eine rausgemacht.
Kann man OTA flashen, Kamera kann man nicht flashen.
Und dann habe ich noch 10 Luftfeuchtigkeits-
und Temperatur-Thermometer fürs Bad.
Kann man auch flashen.
Far Cry 3 Stream.
Weiß nicht. Nee, wahrscheinlich nicht.
Alle Far Crys waren super Spiele.
Ich muss dir sagen, die letzten habe ich nicht angesprochen.
Und 5 Teil 2 hat mich nicht wirklich angesprochen.
Aber vielleicht ist es ja so, wie Vars gesagt hat.
Definition of Insanity.
Man hat es immer drauf, dass was Gutes,
dass was Neues rauskommt, besser ist.
Obwohl man eigentlich schon weiß, dass es nicht so ist.
Wie lange hat der Versand gedauert?
Zehn Tage ungefähr.
Ich habe so über den Daumen gepeilt.
Zehn Tage.
Das ging. Du musst bei AliExpress darauf achten,
welche Versandart und was da steht.
Ich glaube, das hat ungefähr zehn Tage gedauert.
Was lustig ist, der Versand hat, glaube ich, 1,20 Euro gekostet.
Und wenn ich innerhalb von Deutschland mit Hermes was verschicke,
ist es teurer.
Also du musst dich mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Ich kann aus China was bestellen.
Das kommt aus China entweder mit dem Flugzeug oder dem Schiff.
In dem Fall zehn Tage auf jeden Fall nicht mit dem Schiff,
sondern mit dem Flugzeug.
Geht dann über, glaube ich, Niederlande oder Belgien hierher.
Und dann, und dann per Hermes.
Was genau sind das für Thermometers?
Das sind Mi, also Xiaomi, Xiaomi, Mi, wie auch immer.
Das sind die hier, die bei Amazon, glaube ich, 10 Euro kosten.
Das sind die Dinger, die hier acht, die acht, neun Euro kosten.
Bei AliExpress kosten die 2,50.
Habe ich mir gedacht, bestelle ich halt gleich mal zehn Stück.
Oder 3,50 oder so.
Ja, bestelle ich mal zehn Stück.
Braucht man irgendwann mal vielleicht.
Ja.
Welche Lampen kannst du für Smartphone empfehlen?
Nur Liffix oder andere Firmen.
Ich persönlich habe halt ganz, ich habe halt viel Liffix Geschichten,
auch wenn die ein bisschen teurer sind.
Die funktionieren aber ziemlich gut, sind qualitativ auch gut gemacht.
Kann ich mich bis jetzt nicht drüber beschweren.
Andere habe ich glaube noch gar nicht ausprobiert.
Heißt nicht, dass es nicht andere gute Lampen gibt.
Gibt schöne Vergleiche auf YouTube.
Also laut Versand sind die mit dem Flugzeug aus China gekommen.
Und das stand auch Standort China und Versand aus China.
Allerdings.
AOL Werbung von 2004, das bestimmt Grinch.
AOL.
Ainz Jam.
Das ist ja fast so schlimm, wie bin ich schon drin.
Wisst ihr, was die beste, wisst ihr, was die beste Werbung aus den 90ern ist?
Ich zeige euch mal.
Rügenwalder Werbung.
Passt auf hier.
Das hier, beste, beste.
Das beste Werbung.
Das beste Werbung aus den 90ern.
Diese dummen Sorgen habe ich heute immer noch im Kopf teilweise.
Die sind auch nicht schlecht.
Und direkt mitsingen.
Leute, die das mitbekommen haben, kennen das.
Marcel Davies, den gab es auch noch.
So, also, eventuell bin ich heute Abend nochmal on.
Wir müssen noch ein bisschen Frühausschluss machen.
Ich gehe jetzt was futtern.
Heute Abend machen wir Geräte flaschen, wahrscheinlich.
Kann auch sein, dass es nichts wird.
Ihr kennt mich immer, wenn ich sage, ich mache was, mache ich es meistens nicht.
Und wenn es dann keiner mit rechnet, bin ich auf einmal on.
Aber wahrscheinlich flaschen wir heute Abend noch ein paar Geräte.
Bis denn, Leute.
War heute ein bisschen kürzer.
Wir sehen uns.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich noch irgendjemand hosten kann auf die Schnelle.
Ich glaube, es ist keiner da.
Ist der Frazier am Start?
Nope.
Ai Frisi.
Nicht da.
Also Leute, wir sehen uns bis dann.
See you.